So we're totally back,
right?
Yeah.
Experience
Ladies and gentlemen.
We had technological difficulties.
It's probably due to,
uh,
aliens invading our system
or s or CIA and FBI.
If you are FBI.
I just want to say I love your work.
Great Shit.
Don't get us wrong.
We're not enemies of the state.
We know.
We certainly are not mad at you.
Did you see Argo?
Was that the FBI?
No.
No,
we're not.
We're not mad at any.
We're mad at ultimately is
that we're in a broke system,
not the people that are in the [inaudible]
system that are just trying to make a
living.
You know,
I'm the last person that would
be upset at the people that are,
I think human nature.
When you're inside of a situation,
like when you have the kind of ultimate
control of the people that are in the
head of a government.
Anybody that would pass something like
the National Defense Authorization Act or
anybody that would do,
and that's like,
you've gotten to this incredible
position of ultimate control you can do,
you can do some really.
Yeah.
You could do some really ridiculous shit.
I feel bad.
We wanted people to get to that together.
One is I think I'd fuck up too.
If I could see,
I could start for throwing off money,
like just to get a
retirement plan for myself.
Do you understand?
By the way,
that's Ari Shaffir everybody
knows it's Irish fear.
It says it on the iTunes things.
We were always supposed
to be like professional.
Now did I've gotten fucking hours in
without introducing any like who is this?
That's how I should say powerful Ari
Shapiro of former number one on iTunes
bitches respect.
How many weeks were you
number one full week.
A full fucking weak suck
it all you silly bitches.
Yeah,
it was great.
Yeah.
Validation.
Fuck yes.
Oh,
okay.
One of the coolest things about
podcasting is that because of this,
uh,
network of podcasts that
we've all put together,
you know,
that we've all gotten to this
point now where everybody is,
you know,
getting recognized for their stuff.
You know,
Dunkin's doing these shows where he's
fucking selling out like every weekend.
They're these crazy,
ridiculous shows he's doing.
Like every weekend he's packing places.
It's amazing.
And the club owners don't know what
the fight is on gotta wait like what's
happening?
These freaks.
I'm like all these freaks
with cats on their shirt,
on their good drinkers and good tippers.
Yeah.
Nice handful and they're friendly
and weird per Chrysler propaganda.
Bert Kreischer.
So every show,
I've never been to a show that
didn't ever Bert Kreischer tee shirt.
I really every show we got
to deal with one of those,
either Tom or Christina or Dunkin as
somebody that there were like all these
people go to see all of us,
so they should offer like up,
you know,
buy four,
get the next one half
price or whatever it is.
Death Squad members of just like if you
go buy a ticket for Dunkin and Ari and
Tom Segura,
then then Kalin is this much or whatever
it is or get up package and split it
up.
That I guess I would make sense except
someone would have to organize that shit.
It'd be you
have these grandiose plans,
you're not,
I mean we could barely get
these fucking podcasts out.
I'm in.
Yeah.
For Fox asking you,
you're still in the middle
of building this size studio.
It's just takes time.
It takes time to put everything together,
but it should be get Mexican
labor of closer next week then,
then this week,
but it's going to be
cool when it's all done.
It's going to be fun too.
It's a sweet setup,
but yeah,
man,
it is cool it,
there's all this stuff is taken off.
Yeah.
It's beautiful to hear.
Joey Diaz is a,
you know his podcast is always in
the top 10 of iTunes now he's a,
he's killing them.
Yeah.
In the morning.
Does that 5:00 AM,
I'm looking at sleep for two
hours and it's like such a bad,
it's awesome.
I always woke up that early.
Yeah,
he's an animal.
He's the one guy.
Like whenever I would do Kevin and being,
you know,
I have to be up at like
seven o'clock in the morning.
I always call him.
He'll be awake.
Yeah,
we'd go have breakfast together.
We've had breakfast together in Hollywood.
The gang at times.
He used to call me sometimes when he
woke up a little too early and he would
call me at like four 15 just to see.
I was like,
hello,
and he just started laughing.
He's like,
you're still up.
Breakfast and Hollywood is a weird thing,
man.
Oh,
it's good there.
Yeah,
it's good burgers.
Good Punch with a bunch of these places.
The griddle griddle,
but what's,
what's weird is the
people that you run into,
you know,
it's the words that that vibe,
who's up that earliest,
the Hollywood morning vibe.
Hollywood is such as much
as fakers fucking place.
Yeah.
The percentage of fakers.
It's super high.
You feel that in the air,
you know?
Yeah.
I feel like a lack of authenticity
shitting me for no reason.
Yeah,
just asked you what time it is.
It's given me a story.
It's so hard to deal with people,
isn't it?
Or do you guys are hired by the way,
are doing the house of Blues in Chicago.
Powerful.
When is this happening?
November powerful.
November 8th house of Blues in Chicago.
Pack the fucking house
of Blues in Chicago.
That's going to be fun,
man.
Yeah.
That's a main event when people
are driving in for that one.
Yeah,
that sounds,
that sounds sick.
All right.
Should fear,
what is it like man,
it just,
a few years ago you were in this
like crazy struggle situation.
It's the bass.
It's so much bad.
Huh?
He just got to go to these
places and do your stand up.
Yeah.
It's all I wanted to do.
That's all I wanted to do it just go
and tell the jokes I prepared and no one
would let me let me,
nobody else will that me.
I get to the end of a week of like,
so that was pretty good.
Right?
I mean you saw that was for the connect.
You think I can come back
one day at next to no money,
can I please?
And they're like,
Nah.
Ah,
yeah.
They didn't have faith.
That's the greatest come out.
But it's,
you know,
they've heard my album,
it's,
you know what it is,
man.
It's like,
it just,
water seeks its own level eventually.
And if you had all this going on,
you know,
if you were doing podcasts and everybody
would come to see you and you weren't
funny,
it wouldn't be happening.
The it's happening.
It's happening
because of hard work.
It's like you're,
you're in this position,
you know,
it's like the perfect time for you
because your act is really strong now.
It's like,
well,
you know,
you're,
somebody pointed this out too.
Got a lot of new shivs were
thing with a lot of podcasts,
people that,
right.
And because of that,
the comics who do sort of
an honest style of comedy,
just an open and honest style.
It's like that this is a premium put
on that now and so they've already been
doing it.
So it's like,
Oh,
good for you,
right to the right time.
It's very hard
to do that style comedy if that's
not what you've been doing.
If you've been doing a sort
of contrived bullshit act,
it's,
it's very tough to drop that
be real early on.
It's what everybody does.
It's just like,
let me,
here's the joke I wrote,
I guess.
Yeah.
You ever go back and listen
to some of your early shit?
I put one up for shits and giggles once,
like an early,
early set.
Yeah,
and then I was like,
this is just to know someone's
going to see that something.
This is amazing.
It's just know it's taken us down bad.
It's fucking hard man.
And in the worst too was people were
writing in like so funny and I'm like,
you're wrong.
You're way wrong.
What have you liked?
Everybody thinks they can do it though.
Have you ever,
I mean everybody that's
got any sort of confidence,
there's always the that question
and I've been thinking about doing,
stand up prepared some stuff.
Tell me what you think.
And they're like,
go over this stuff with you and shit.
You're like,
Oh God,
it's pressed to how terrible
I go dissuade you.
But well look man,
I go,
okay.
You know,
I wa,
I mean,
who the fuck knows?
They might be able to do it.
But realistically,
if you're like,
if I can give you an honest answer
without hurting anyone's feelings,
you would have to tell them like,
look,
you've just started this so of
course you're going to be God awful.
Yeah.
That's hard for people to accept though.
Especially smart people.
Smart people think that.
Yeah.
You know what though,
man,
I know.
Stand up.
I listened to it.
I've,
I've have watched it on TV before I
think or have an idea how to do it.
I'm just gonna bypass all.
Did you think to get that
with fucking farming?
You want to tell you how to plan a tomato
10 years and you'll be way better at
it.
Yeah,
that's with everything.
But standup is that what people don't
understand when they're watching it is
that there's a,
there's a hypnosis going on.
It's not as simple as someone saying
something and you're reacting to that.
There is a little ride that
a standup takes you on.
You know when,
when when someone's good and
you watch them to this day,
like you get caught up in their,
their groove and you know,
you're like,
you're like tune into them.
You're like,
there's,
there's an exchange going on that it's
not as simple as everybody wants to make
it seem like you say something funny.
Ha Ha,
this person laughs.
Not that simple.
That's why when you say tosh does
something wrong by spending a rape joke,
you're like,
you weren't there.
You don't know about the whole situation.
He set up the last however long
he's built his crowd into something.
We're now,
he can do what he wants.
Your God,
Shit.
I remember early on you were like,
I can't open with that.
Yeah,
I've tried.
It won't work.
You've got to give him like 40 minutes
of like calmed down before it can hit him
that yeah,
like the
whole,
that's the whole thing that I
was used to do on Noah's Ark.
Yeah.
That all the people who
just do would get upset,
which is hilarious.
Yes.
You have to get them on your side first.
And if you did it and they'd be like,
it's just not funny.
Well,
it's also then in people didn't know
what to expect to come to one of my shows
and they would think there's going
to get the guy from fear factor.
That's all my fault by holding it up,
I'm doing shit like fear factor taken,
taken money for those silly shows.
He said bad precedent.
We were like this.
They had a cut.
You're like,
but fears not a factor for you.
Oh no,
it wasn't.
It's never hard to do.
You know?
I would never be a so pompous to pretend
that it's actually difficult to do.
It's,
it's still an amazing job.
Why did you start getting high
while you were doing it too?
Okay.
Season two so you knew it was coming back.
The ratings were high.
Yeah.
Well I just started getting high
around when season one happen,
but I didn't get high at work.
See,
I know what to get white at
and what not to get high at.
You went from not smoking at all
to smoking at work within a year.
Oh yeah.
Wow.
I was like,
this is fun.
Gets a bunch of years.
Yeah.
Y Yeah.
I right away went to feeling
very comfortable with it
going on stage with it.
Hi.
Yeah,
it's just right away.
I recognize that this is
like some crazy truth serum.
Like it's not,
it's,
it's another thing.
It's not as simple as it seems.
You look at marijuana and all those guys
were getting high and you just escaping
reality.
It's actually doing the
exact opposite of escape.
You're seeing reality for what it is.
Diving into it with the lights
on as bright as possible.
It's not,
there's nothing escape about getting high.
This is what people don't understand.
It's,
it's not,
that's not what you're looking for.
Especially when you're smoking.
Sativas which another problem,
people don't know that there's two
completely different effects at two
completely different types of marijuana.
Half.
I feel like telling that
to people when they say,
I'm sure you the too,
when I say like,
oh,
I don't like weed.
I'm like,
I don't want to insult you.
But like what we'd,
if you had,
yeah,
you don't really know
what you're talking about.
You know,
and the people that say that
it makes it makes me sleepy.
It's,
well,
some we,
you can do that.
Let me give you some other way.
Yeah.
This guy was sleeping at
a party and some major,
a desktop they'll go on is
hilarious.
Oh my God.
Meanwhile,
how much did they finger this guys?
That is hilarious,
dude.
Pat On this guy's ass.
That's amazing.
And they all signed
their names all over it.
Look,
people sign names,
however it just signing him.
Oh my God,
that's amazing.
I had a picture of me as well,
my flight when I got there because the
drinking age is 18 and I was drunk,
Barf in a sink,
like leaned over it to read
those in my ear and my nose.
My friends had put all over
me at toothpaste drawn on
me and that picture got
back to my mom.
I don't know.
Not back there.
So fucking embarrassed by it.
Oh my God.
How hammered were you that
you didn't know limits?
Tequila slammers you've ever
had to kill the slammer,
the shittiest Tequila.
Put little sprite in it and one
of those triple shot glasses.
Yeah.
You just slam it and then just drink it.
You have to learn limits.
Huh?
You just keep drinking
until you're throwing up.
Like literally last shot of going down.
You're like,
well hold it.
Yeah,
that's the problem with drinking.
You know?
That's something we could use
drinking schamens we really could,
you know,
I mean there's Schamens
for Iowasca as the deal.
Why don't they teach
you about it in schools?
You're going to get into it,
but they still don't bother teaching you.
Well,
let's just pretend like
abstinence is the best policy.
We should promote abstinence.
I,
why would you do that?
What you doing or what can never
totally going to happen on that trip?
We went into phrase at that
second semester of senior year,
we all went there.
I was talking to more my friends about it.
Like why wouldn't they
tell us about drinking?
Please.
People are going to fuck to okay,
they're going to fuck.
And I'm going to drink.
You know why?
Cause that's fine.
Okay.
People are going to fuck and
people are going to drink.
Why don't they talk about that?
You can't be against educating
people about condoms.
If you've ever seen an episode
of 16 and pregnant you,
you're no longer against condoms.
They're like,
you got to teach these people.
You should be a better way than condoms.
There should be like a
really effective way.
I was told me,
give you a shot and it's called a fortune
dude.
If you have,
you have had an abortion with a check
or gone where it girls had an abortion.
You know what that's like,
but if they make it good with like lasers,
like Bam,
you're done.
You just got to a board it next,
Bam,
you got to it.
I can take a shot and be like,
you'd be sterile for the next two days.
Look,
yeah.
What are the side effects?
I know this girl that's on something
that she gets a shot or something and it
lasts like four years.
Why are,
yeah,
yeah.
What's it called?
The Nuva Ring.
Yeah.
She's like,
you could total cum dumpster because
of that because you can do whatever you
want.
They have like four periods a year.
Is that one of those?
It's like inside.
Here's why doesn't every girl,
same thing with girls on on
on fucking birth controls.
The same thing with weed where
it's like have you had all of them?
Cause there's new types now,
but it's kind of creepy though that
you're pumping chemicals in your body like
that and you're tricking your
body into thinking linear,
pregnant.
I mean,
I don't know.
What is the longterm effects of tricking
your body into thinking that it's
pregnant?
I Dunno.
Doctors.
Delicious Pussy.
Yeah.
No worry about baby.
I don't know have some negative effects
more than fucking having to work a
second job at the docks.
But those two things have that people
can't control when they're young is sex
and alcohol.
Those are two things.
He just,
both of them,
both of them were completely
overwhelming for you.
One of those kids talking and he was just
some nerd who never got laid with some
fat Mexican and never got laid.
And it was just like,
he was just like,
no,
I love you.
Oh my gosh.
And it was like you don't
know anything about anything.
And then a year later he won't talk to
her and then just figuring out who's
going to raise the baby.
It's just like,
oh,
you don't know anything.
Being a child and having a
kid as far as I am fucked up.
It's fucked up for everybody.
It's fucked up for the kid too.
It's yes,
but then the question becomes when you're
supposed to prevent it after the fact
or before the fact and if after the fact,
is it just you have to just accept
it or can you have an abortion?
And of course they're
going to have an abortion.
Of course you can.
But the Kim medical age.
Okay,
but to what age?
How old could the fetus be?
Nine months.
What do you think?
I Dunno.
What do you think,
Brian?
What I do think though is that it's not
as simple as everybody likes to say,
no,
it's killing a baby.
We're adults who are making decisions
that we don't want to make this light
that's deep.
That's deep.
It's a heavy decision,
you know?
It really is.
That's what we've put onto human life for.
Like it comes out,
we're like look,
like when it comes to a certain level,
it's like when it's a bunch of cells,
when it's like 30 cells,
okay,
then it doesn't seem real then it seems
like you'd be able to get rid of it and
not even feel bad.
Yeah.
But at what point in time,
how easy is it to market it better?
You know,
if it was like
person like Betty White market it for you.
I do like the marketing techniques they
have is because of the pro life and
fourth choice.
When you think about just their names,
they're not at odds.
Both pro choices and
they're both pro life.
Yeah.
Isn't that funny?
Pro Choice.
That's a funny way of putting it because
otherwise it's pro life or pro death or
pro choice or anti choice.
Yeah.
It's pro life or pro choice.
You know,
those aren't opposites.
Yeah.
It's one aspect of the subject.
You know,
what choice are you making?
Hold on.
Just a kid.
Just call it a choice to kill pro choice.
Everybody's fucking pro choice.
That's just my choice is
different than your choice.
Exactly.
That is a creepy thing though.
The idea that people would be anti choice.
That's why when someone calls themselves
pro choice like sets you up to fail
when you competing against,
you know,
you know you can't,
they're saying they're pro choice if they
just were the pro baby killing party.
Yeah.
Who does that?
That's what I'm in favor of.
That's not going to make you money.
I talked to girls before,
I have sex sometimes and I'm like,
you know,
what have you had and how
do we feel about abortion?
Well,
it's a heavy conversation right away.
Ari's mercenary about it.
I don't want to fucking get that thing.
We just,
Oh,
I didn't know that.
She would never have an
abortion if anything happened.
Yeah,
cause I wouldn't bother asking.
Just saying the words wants.
It's a little uncomfortable.
So I'm going to raise some kid.
I don't want for fucking 10 years
or however long you'd have to.
Isn't it crazy?
So you just,
I just ask,
isn't it crazy?
That would just,
you play in like,
like when you're,
when you're not trying to
have a baby with a check,
it's actually not to,
you're playing this game
of trickery with nature.
Like nature's only reward me with those
awesome feelings cause that's how you
make humans,
you know,
and imagine how much it feels,
how good it feels.
If you're not even masturbating.
I give,
you're not masturbating and you'd just
a person and neither one of you ever
masturbate and you get together
naked and you wind up fucking like,
oh my God.
Of course you're going to come inside her.
Of course she's going to make a person.
That's how they rocked it.
Caveman just keeps feeling
good and they stopped.
It would never stop.
It was two people went,
oh wait a minute.
Babies come
a little pull out.
No,
no.
We had to figure out what makes
the baby part Louie bit about it.
No,
but if animals had to watch humans,
like animal planet version of humans,
they'd be like,
see this meeting and then we pull out
and shit on the floor or something like,
but you were so close.
What are you doing?
That's funny.
I thought I said tell my friends in
college when I was still a virgin that
masturbation was the same
as sex and they were like,
Ari,
you're wrong.
I'm like,
no,
you guys are idiots.
It's the same thing that's happening
physically to your genitalia.
How could it feel better?
It's the same act and they were like,
you just don't get it.
How could you think that your hand
could be as good as a pussy because you
coming would be the same.
That's you coming as you coming.
Wow,
that's interesting.
Isn't it funny that that's not the case?
That's not at all the case.
Like when you're really into
a chick and she's really sexy,
you rang especially a little drunk and
you love each other and you come like,
Oh God,
I feel so good.
It's amazing.
Sweet corn in the morning.
It's supposed to be to
make you make people.
That's really what,
that's why it feels so good.
You can't even think straight on.
It's a biological trick.
It's a wonderful one.
Wipe off the tip and put it back in.
It's me.
If you had to think about that with a
straight mind wiping off the tip and
putting it back in but
not be a viable option.
How about this one?
Just let me rub it on the outside.
She had ever taken place ever in
the history of the human race.
It was on one of my cds.
Okay.
That's your best match
I've ever done right there.
That's right.
I forgot about that.
Okay,
cool.
Dude.
Working at this store,
like as an employee,
as a fucking door man and cover
booth guy just helps you so much.
Watch all these fucking great comics and
you just watch them and learn technique
and shit.
You get to see them do
the same jokes a lot too.
It was interesting as a guy learning
how to do it because everybody wants to
think as an audience member that that
a person on stage saying something.
That's the first time I've ever said it.
You really can't do that every time.
I mean we kind of can,
but it won't be as good.
Trust me,
it's better if we write stuff out.
It's better if we practice
things a few times.
It's better if you get it on.
Then there's this certain bits.
No,
there's certain bits where
it right out of the gate.
They're awesome.
It's cool.
But it happens.
You can't guarantee when those
are coming in when they're not.
You know,
there's something in Indianapolis.
I came back to my show second
time cause he came one night,
then he got my album,
which was different of the call up,
holocaust available revenge for the
Holocaust Ladies Gentlemen available on
Itunes,
Amazon.
But he was like,
oh,
it's different.
So I figured I'd come back again,
see another show and he just sat
up front and I couldn't even look.
He was on my right.
I did my whole act from straight to left.
I couldn't even look over there.
I was like,
dude,
you shouldn't come back.
And he was like the same jokes.
That's so creepy.
It's a mind.
Fuck.
I feel so fake.
Yeah.
I mean,
you got to get over that son.
You are fake fat faker.
You didn't just think of
something when you're up there.
God dammit.
You worked on it every
night for six months.
I just realized,
no you didn't.
You're fucking line
the death squad,
Ohio guys.
They go the boat shows,
they'll go to like these seven o'clock
show and the nine o'clock show.
So it's just like you guys,
it becomes a bit of a gay circle joke.
At a certain point.
I sort of get it where it's like
you can see like modest mouse.
There's some band like two times in a row.
Yeah,
I'll do to
more than once in a row.
I went to see bill Hicks twice in a row.
I saw a bunch of guys back in the day
where I saw the same act more than once.
Joe Loads aren't used to come to,
uh,
to our shows when we did
none of the way and shows.
Oh yeah.
And uh,
and there was this joke,
have you just make a bunch of Jitsu?
Um,
I guess I can do it now.
I never do it anymore,
but like,
uh,
I've got the way that you just,
it was invented was some Brazilian guy,
uh,
came on work from early one day,
came home early from work one day and
found his wife did not have dinner ready
for him.
So he's choking her because
of that fucking choking
the life out of her and the
girl's father comes in cause I live
in the same fucking hut in Brazil.
And um,
he goes,
what are you doing?
You're doing it wrong.
You got to fucking put hooks
in and then come from behind.
And that's how Jujitsu was invented.
That's my theory.
But I was,
I used to love that joke and I was like,
you seen it though?
And he goes out every sucks.
I was like,
I haven't done any research on it.
Uh,
but he goes,
no,
I like to sing it like slightly different.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
See you're a fan of
standup then I get that.
Yeah.
There's certain guys that
had jokes that I would,
I would call out for like a,
when Holtzman was on stage,
who would always do that?
[inaudible] into a rage.
He would do this joke about a sosh.
Oh,
that's a fucking funny guy.
Never see him at the store anymore,
man.
I was never there.
My son,
my son's a homosexual.
He's my new favorite to call out.
Like just hear his jokes.
He's,
he's,
Oh yeah,
we used to do this.
They doing an hour and 10 set
minute sets the other day.
He's been doing really long sets now.
Closed up the main room show on Constance.
Awesome.
And they just all stay.
As long as your audience stays.
I'm doing the laugh factory.
And more night at the
time were where were,
well I had done the laugh
factory and decades probably.
Oh,
probably 10 years.
Yeah.
I haven't done it forever,
but I'm gonna do it tomorrow night.
I think it's like an eight o'clock
show when I go on like nine ish,
somewhere around nine nine
30 something like that.
Daddy d is just got
back from a long beach.
She said he loved it.
Yeah.
We should all go there.
Bet You really got to fill it up.
I like to see what it's like full,
but it's a,
it's a rock venue.
It's a cool area because I've stayed
at the hotel is there a few times.
It's so here's how big it
is when they introduce you.
By the time you can get to the mic,
it feels uncomfortable
in that time were like,
oh,
I should be talking now.
Really?
It's such a long walk to them.
Like a theater.
It was a fucking old rock
place with a big stage.
600 people maybe.
Yeah,
something like that.
Wow.
So,
uh,
it's big as a Phoenix,
the standup life in Phoenix,
it's bigger than that.
Really.
The,
just because it's more stage room and
standard blind and Phoenix is 600 seats,
right?
It's 50 it's bigger than six 50.
Wow.
Well the scope of it is bigger anyway.
Oh,
I see.
To the wall and stuff.
Yeah.
It's right next to so many to stores and
restaurants that stand up live is the
most intimate 600 you could get
because even though it was 600 seats,
it felt like it's like a club,
but just keeps going.
Yeah.
It felt like once we worked out,
if you would please Jen on the first show,
there was a problem with the microphone.
We'll monitor.
It was no minor,
so you can hear yourself.
There's a rider somehow I have a rider
that I didn't know it was that weird
shit.
Yeah,
and one of the things on is that
I have to have a wireless mic.
I don't need a fucking
wireless Mike Wireless Mikes.
It's,
I know for when you do like theaters,
like the more theater
in Seattle or whatever.
It was like,
just make sure you have everything right.
We need them because they don't
know sometimes the stand up,
but even then,
I don't need a wireless one.
Having James Mooney and it's Kevin.
I met Kevin.
James is rider.
He gets red wine and right where I,
yeah,
that's why I was like,
why?
Why?
Why aren't you
there too?
Right.
It was a weird man.
San Francisco this weekend we got,
um,
Brian's coming with me or are you doing
Greg Fitzsimmons is coming as well.
She'd be a lot of fun.
We're doing Knob Hill Masonic Center.
We're going to do that on Friday night.
And then Seattle on Saturday night,
the Moore Theater,
the more theater is sold out.
That's a really good room.
But there are uh,
there,
there's still some tickets
left for the Nob hill show.
So that's San Francisco Friday night.
Greg Fitzsimmons who's fucking hilarious.
If you never seen Greg
Fitzsimmons who's standing up.
Greg and I started out
together like literally like
a week apart from each other
way back in 1988.
And uh,
I've been friends with him ever since.
He's a fucking hilarious standup.
Like he's really fucking good.
So I'm really excited to give you guys
a fun show and if you haven't seen me
there for a while,
I got a lot of new shit.
So we're going to be real fun.
So nob hill,
masonic center,
Friday night and then
the more theater side.
And I,
I think the more sold out
though because Nob Hill,
I dunno,
it's like a couple thousand seats.
Wow.
Actually we cool.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
That's a massive show.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I just was talking to them and I just
thought like maybe it would be cool if
Greg would come with me on the road
to a couple of gigs here and there.
So solid too.
And I would love for people to see him,
you know,
and all these shows to see him.
You know,
I think one of the coolest things about
doing this podcast and doing all these
shows is that is it,
we can all sort of blow each other up,
you know,
and then we can all show you
everybody who Brian Cowan is,
you know,
show everybody who Dunkin is and you all,
yeah.
With Hollywood style of making it,
there's only a certain size,
the pious and everyone is just slice.
But now there's just an unlimited pie.
Yeah.
This is like,
you can have as much,
you have your own pie factory,
Oliver.
On Pie factory.
Yeah.
It's fascinating.
It's a really interesting thing,
man.
Yeah.
So tell me about this hunting thing.
So yeah.
Um,
so I went hunting.
Who'd you go with with Callan?
Brian Cowen and uh,
this dude named Steve Rinella
was this a cougar hunt?
But thinking,
God,
how dare you Brian.
That's the kind of Huts Brian understands.
He knows,
he knows how to attract that prey.
He walks in all drunk and limping.
He told me it was like,
he was like,
where's broken?
And he was like broken than
Minnesota fucking whatever.
Montana,
Montana hunting when hunting in Montana,
this dude Steven Rinella,
I became a fan of his show.
He had a show on the travel
channel called the wild within.
He's an author and he knows a lot
about the history of the wild west.
And that was one of the coolest things
about the weekend is getting to talk to
him about wild west stories and shit.
Oh Dude.
He knows everything.
He knows like all the different,
you know,
incidents between the
Indians and the white men,
the white men breaking the treaties
and the wars that took place.
And we were camping on the Missouri
River where Lewis and Clark camped.
That's where we camped.
And we did all our travel
by canoe or by hiking.
Really?
Yeah,
it was fucking intense.
So when you hiked by the Missouri River,
was anyone else around?
We saw in the five days we were there,
we traveled 40 plus miles
down the Missouri River.
And in all that time we
saw three other boats.
Whoa.
And then when you got off and was
like walking around and stuff?
Well,
once we got out at the very end,
we were in a place where there was a
bridge and it was cars and traffic and
stuff like that.
It's down.
Ah,
over those five days we
saw nothing but canoes.
We saw it three or four canoes.
It was mostly just us.
And we had a satellite phone in
case we had like an emergency.
Um,
and what we did was we pulled in,
we got there,
uh,
on Monday and on Monday
we got in a plane are we,
we got in a boat rather um,
road a road down the
river kind of playing.
What the fuck am I talking about?
Got on a plane to get there.
Um,
we had to drive two hours
from billings to the rivers,
the Missouri River billings.
Montana is a very small place but a very
nice like cool small town cop a map.
And uh,
we drove two and a half hours
to the river.
And then when,
what you just say the mayor?
No,
no,
I said we drove to the river.
Okay.
We drove to the river and
then once he's too high,
yes.
For a store and he's too
high to pay attention.
Drive the river.
No,
he said the mayor.
Did you say the man?
He said the word mayor.
Dude,
I'm telling a fucking important
and life changing story.
You can't tell me when they like
timing with every fucking breath.
I have question spewing mouths.
I tried to tell you about a
beautiful life changing experience.
So,
so we're on this,
we're on this river.
Well,
the first night we get there,
it's pouring rain.
We sleep in tents.
It's fucking freezing outside.
I mean it's really cold
like 33 34 degrees.
Just w just cold enough so it
doesn't snow but the rain comes down.
It's just ridiculously miserable.
Then we get up in the morning.
Have warmers or anything?
Nope.
You just sleeping bags
at that night like I,
this was a bad idea.
No Man,
I was committed.
I was 100% committed.
I was like,
look,
if I'm going to do this,
I'm going to do this the right way with
this Guy Rinella believes in is what's
called a fair chase hunt.
And what that means is like there's
certain people that have like a,
they have property like a giant
ranch and it's like a high fence.
And so there's all these deer inside this,
this ranch and he like set up a stand
and then there'll be like a little feeder
that goes off and it goes off
at the same time every morning.
And it drops food and the animals come
in and get the food and you blast him.
Oh,
that's exactly what though.
I mean not just trick them.
I mean it's like the
ultimate setup as well.
Just get your foot in the supermarket.
Exactly.
And if that's how you were approaching it,
I can understand that.
Like say if you lived on that
farm and that's how you look,
if that's actually smart,
because it's a lot smarter than you know,
at going hunting,
going and hunting for it.
You should,
you know,
control your environment better.
You need that food.
It's not like you can
do it like as a sport.
But we,
uh,
we went,
we went and did everything the hard way.
We hiked every morning
for about three miles,
uh,
over this mountain.
These like these hills
that were made out of,
they're made out of like a clay that
used to be the great inland Western,
see great western inland sea,
Great Western inland sea.
And uh,
during the Jurassic period,
there was fucking dinosaurs
there and there's fossilize.
It was a shallow,
warm water ocean where Montana is.
So when you are a walking around there
you find like fossilized shells like in
the strata,
you know like when things break off they
also find buffalo skulls all the time.
Like in the strata because,
well what a strata.
Me the,
you know how the earth has
like layers to it though?
Well those layers,
if you cut a slice through the earth,
those layers represent errors and you
can tell by how far it goes down by
whatever measurement,
how many thousands,
millions of years it was.
And you saw like a place
that cut out and stuff?
Yeah.
You see like fossilize
shells like on the ground,
I mean it the,
the place it's called the bad lands.
All right.
And it is,
it's,
it's really cool,
timid dating.
It's a very,
very intimidating place because there's
this river and then there's she's
fucking mountains that are covered with
this clay shit and you're trying to walk
in it,
you're sliding all over the place.
It's really difficult to get a
footing because it's essentially silt,
silt from the bottom of the ocean.
It's covered this whole
thing and it freezes up and
then it gets wet and it gets
wet,
becomes muck and it freezes up again.
So when it's hard,
you can walk on it,
no problem.
But when it becomes wet,
it's just a fucking crazy nightmare.
So we were climbing these wet hills
of this shit and it's exhausting.
I mean really exhausting.
And you're doing it for,
you do that for several
hours in the morning.
And then we would go in a row row the
canoes down river for several miles.
And then once we would get out,
then we would go and hike for several
more miles to get back and there a deer.
You pull up your,
your canoe,
he said camp.
And then you go and look for deer.
Bears are predators.
They're predators or Wa we
saw a mountain lion shit.
And they attack humans a lot.
No,
there's too many of us.
And we have rifles.
We probably be would be safe.
But you never can tell if you're in
the wrong situation at the wrong time.
Hunger and amount.
Yeah.
For Mountain Lions old,
if it can't catch a deer anymore,
you know,
if it's starving,
if you catch them,
you can just catch them.
But where you were camping
at night like by the river,
that was okay.
Yeah.
While we were camping at sites
where you're allowed camp,
you know you're allowed to set up and we,
you know,
after the first night it
stopped raining so we,
we made fires.
But the,
the nighttime man,
when you,
first of all it's fucking freezing.
Like we've got down to as
cold as 12 degrees spin.
No,
it didn't spill.
We slept in separate tents
were all sleeping outside.
I mean we're outside in the fucking,
I mean you,
you have to zip yourself up in these,
you wear a wool underwear,
you wear like thermal,
like,
like long John Tyler wool underwear.
And then you were on top of that,
like a thick pair of these wool pants.
And then on top of that I've got,
you know,
a above me of God will long,
long underwear top and then two layers
and then a jacket and then a down coat
over the jacket.
And then I'm inside the sleeping bag
in the down coat with a hood up and the
hood on the sleeping bag and
you're barely able to do it.
It's fucking cold.
But once you get in there for awhile,
especially once I've realized
to sleep with the jacket on,
like I thought I should
probably take my layers off,
but it was too cold.
It's you to rule part.
Yeah.
It sucks.
It sucks a masturbating,
right?
Yeah.
I held my loads,
I held my loads for strength and it,
it benefited me in for my endurance.
Cause it was a,
it was a difficult thing to do.
You know,
it seems,
it seems like,
you know,
you're whining about like,
I work out.
I do,
I do tough stuff.
you know,
uh,
like hard kettlebell workouts.
I do Jujitsu,
very difficult things.
But this hiking shit,
when you're,
you're hiking around in mud all day,
you know,
uphill.
It's fucking hard,
man.
You,
you,
you really,
you know,
you really get winded.
It's a,
your heart rate gets up.
It's a really good workout and you know,
it's,
it feels like honest,
like you're really fucking getting some,
you really doing something and you know,
you're like,
and then you get in the boat.
So I was like,
I was enjoying it from a,
an an athletic stance.
How was,
I was like,
this is a good workout.
No,
there was never warm.
It never got more than in the
30s it was like the warmest,
it was probably like 34 35 degrees.
Like,
well,
every time we were there
where water would turn to ice,
it was always constantly turning.
The more people there when
the summertime is cool.
Yeah,
yeah.
I'm sure.
But that's not,
the hunting season starts and
you want to go deer hunting.
See this,
this area is,
it doesn't have a lot of biodiversity
according to Steven Rinella.
But what it does have is it has a lot of
certain types of animals that you could
find.
And there's not like,
you don't see a lot of animals,
but when every now and
then you'll see a deer.
Like there's one in every now
and then you'll see a ram.
We saw a lot of rams.
Yeah,
dude,
they're fucking impressive.
These,
uh,
big horn sheep and they're there.
They're walking across the tops of,
in the ledges of these mountains and
you're watching them just like really,
really perilous situations
and they're walking like,
they're so sure footed.
It's really kind of crazy to watch.
And they're so bad ass curly horns.
Nah,
I don't think so.
I don't think you have
to get too close to,
I blow,
you shouldn't get close to him.
But,
uh,
I think if you're not trying
to do something to them,
they didn't seem,
seem to be interested in us.
Apparently that's a really hard animal
to get a tag for it to hunt because they
reintroduced them to Colorado
and they built up the,
uh,
the numbers.
And so it's very difficult to get a tag,
especially where we were to hunt him.
It's not like when you,
when you go hunting,
it's not like everybody can go hunting.
He like if safe,
there's certain species,
it's very hard to get a tag for
it even if you live in that state.
So they only say like,
let's say only time people
can hunt these things.
Yes.
It's one of those things,
and you might have a million
people that are trying to hunt,
you know?
But Deere is one of the ones
that you literally have to hunt.
If you don't hunt deer,
then they have starvation issues.
They have overpopulation issues.
They interfere with traffic that it
becomes a real problem if there's roads or
anything,
or people are driving along
because these animals,
in order to get food,
they have to travel all over the place.
Now there are a lot of them are nocturnal
and they'll run across the road and
there's,
there's certain parts of the country
right now where if you're driving around
the road at night,
it's fucking scary.
You could slam it.
A deer's left and right.
I,
I've,
I don't remember,
I think it was Iowa.
There's some ungodly amount of deer
are killed in car accidents every year.
It's like 100,000 because
it runs into the cause.
There's so many of them.
There's,
they're fucking all over the place.
And for,
for people that don't understand
how conservation works,
it's really interesting,
but the majority of the money,
in fact,
all of the money that goes
to wildlife groups like,
um,
uh,
like the,
um,
the,
the groups that put a bag limits on,
uh,
on hunting,
you know,
whatever the agency,
whatever name of for
the agencies they are.
And I don't know what,
what they would,
what they call themselves,
but whatever they are,
that fishing game,
you know,
whatever that is.
But those,
all their money comes from hunting.
So the,
all the,
the money for regulating
like the population,
reintroducing animals that were wiped out,
all of that comes from hunting.
And there's some people I can
understand their point of view.
Some people think that we
should have no hunting and uh,
you know,
that that hunting is cruel
and it animals is cruel.
And I,
I can totally understand
that point of view too.
I totally understand animals well,
I liked,
look,
the,
the type of person that would say you
shouldn't kill an animal cause killing
animals.
Accrual is a nice person.
That's a person that wants
to be nice to animals.
So I can't see how I would
want to argue with that.
You know,
I can see your point.
But ultimately if I look
at it pragmatically,
my thoughts have always been that,
listen,
these animals are going to die whether
we'd them or whether a coyote eats them
or amount might need some.
We found giant mountain lions shits
with hair on them with deer hair on him.
Oh really?
Yeah.
It's really creepy.
It's really creepy cause
you're just thinking this,
this motherfucker killed
this deer with his face.
Wow.
Like what a bad ass cat.
This is juicy.
That video of a,
the coyotes get killed
getting killed by the wolf's.
Yes.
Oh yeah.
They rip it apart as don't have hands.
Well the wild is a very
fascinating thing man.
And being out there for five
days with no cell phone,
no Internet,
no TV,
no radio,
just sleeping outside and
eating outside for five days.
It was very strange.
And you're stalking an animal.
You're stalking animals.
And occasionally we'd see them,
they were too far away and uh,
we had to get up wind of them if we were,
if we were,
if we were a,
if we were up wind and the wind
was going down to them our way,
they could smell us.
So we had to make sure that we were
always in a situation where the wind was
blowing towards us,
like from the animal to us.
So at the animal couldn't smell us
and we're going to creep up on them.
You would see it from far,
far away and then try to track it down.
We see them from far,
far away and then we would duck behind
things and then we would try to go all
the way around like that
depending on where the wind was.
It's very important.
How far down my first
vote we smelled so bad.
We were there with no
showers for five days.
Okay.
So you could smell my ass from Mars.
Sas must've been terrible heads.
Yeah.
You're,
you're taking shits in these,
these eco bags.
It's like the whole thing was horrific.
Yeah.
Like this,
this certain type of bag that's for
human waste so that you don't like leave
your shit laying around
on the Missouri River.
As long as their shit,
you don't,
what's gross?
People don't want to step in your shit.
Meanwhile there's cow shit everywhere.
It's really wild because it's not wild.
It's fucking deaf human shit of like
one of the worst things you could ever
encounter.
Yeah.
Carb diets are disgusting and none natural
filled with preservatives and things
of fucking ferment inside are assholes.
And then it comes pouring out
and the most wretched smell ever.
Even dog shit doesn't smell
nearly as bad as human shit.
Human Shit smells dog shit in the house.
Like I think a dog shit.
Oh Fuck Ross.
She go shit.
Like I had the biggest fogo shit the
other day and I put a t I wanted to just
put a $20 bill on it and not flush it
to somebody would try to grab that $20
bill just to see it.
Cause you know,
I don't want him,
you know,
I didn't want them.
We'll take a look.
Let's try it.
Anyway,
so,
so we're out there for,
you know,
two,
three days.
On the third day was when I
killed a deer and we were,
before that we had seen a couple of
them but we couldn't get close enough to
shoot him.
Hold on.
How far down?
When do you have to be?
Like two miles away.
You're okay.
But like how close can,
you can be close as long as the wind is
going from them to you and then it's a
matter of sound.
But then if it's not,
if it's going towards them,
like how far away do you have to circle
around them to get it all depends
because it's not a distance thing.
It's a being behind things thing and
it's being above them thing you want.
Ideally you want them below you and you're
above from like the top of the hills.
Will you also be of more shots at
them if they have more opportunities?
If they're going like up over
the hill and you shoot at them,
they take off over the top of the hill.
You didn't know where they're going.
They went left or right.
You have no idea where they are.
If you look down on them,
you could see where they are better.
So you could scan more area too.
It's Kinda hard to figure out
where they're going to go.
It's,
it's a really interesting
thing because it's your,
you become a part of their world.
I mean,
you're walking around,
you'll live in outside.
You're,
you're doing this for
several days and you're,
you're becoming a party's animal's world.
You don't talk all day,
all day spent trying to walk as
slowly and quietly as possible.
Stopping every 15 to 20
sites sounds like off scan.
It just can't relax to scan the horizon
to look around for these animals.
So you're,
you're doing this all day and um,
you,
you're not talking,
you know,
very rarely.
It's like,
you know,
maybe he'll say,
okay,
we're going to try over
here now on this one.
Are you tracking anything?
Sometimes we'll see a lot of tracks.
You see a lot of a deer footprints.
We saw elk footprints.
A lot of Ram flipped,
but we saw an amazing amount of Ram.
So it was,
it was incredible.
How many of those,
he's bighorn sheep.
We saw you following the tracks.
Are you just walking into,
so you're following the trails
that the deer's traveling,
cause it deer's traveling trails and
then they'll go off into the wooded areas
to bed down.
So they get up in the morning.
Then in the morning they,
uh,
they were up and they get
water and eat and they'll,
they'll stay active for a little while
and then they start going in the mid day
to bed down and then they come
out when it gets dark again.
Like we had one come through our camp
while we're sleeping and we heard it.
You just hear a goal that he gets scared.
It's,
it came through the camp and as
it's in this cabinet realize like,
oh my God,
I'm surrounded by Ogres the monsters
at want to eat me right there.
And it sort of freaks out and starts
stomping his feet and a fuck of a 10 if
they want to.
Oh yeah.
It could.
Of course it could,
you know,
I mean,
they're not aggressive.
It's not like they would do that
unless they were threatened.
You know,
they're there.
They're clearly prey.
You know,
they're clearly there.
There clearly pray for
all these different,
uh,
predators like especially mountain lions,
but humans of course.
And that's what they're worried about.
Wolves will be an issue.
They just want to walk
around and they want to fuck.
That's what it is.
It's getting close.
We weren't there during the Rut,
during the Rut.
It's really crazy because the deer gets
super bold cause they just have hard ons
and they just want to go fuck.
And they'll just walk right across the
street and like look at you and you can
blast them.
It's a,
it gets to be really,
it's really like a ruthless trick,
you know,
because,
um,
they're,
they're being silly.
So that's why people put the smell of it.
You're on the female deer.
Yeah,
yeah.
Well they spray it on them.
They'll spray it on things.
You know,
there's,
I think some places that's illegal though.
There's,
there's different places like didn't
have different laws and regulations.
I learned a lot from hanging out with
the Steve Rinella guy was a fascinating
thing.
Should have those rules.
Like girls shouldn't be able to
dress like sluts and that's like our,
you know what I mean?
Yeah,
absolutely.
I don't,
fear comes up and he's like,
oh,
can I fuck,
it's some other thing and I can't fuck.
So of girls were trying to rip you off.
Like if girls were like professional gold
diggers shouldn't be allowed to dress
like sluts yes.
To let's,
you're willing to back it up.
Hmm.
Okay.
I see your point.
You are a female deer.
Yeah.
You can make that smell.
That's okay.
It seemed like that,
that would be very stressful.
Like,
did you ever get to a point
where you're just like,
all right,
I really just want to just
yell and tweet and fighting,
you know,
like walk around it.
No,
no,
no.
I was able to,
um,
uh,
I was able to sort of accept that this
was how we're living for the next few
days.
And uh,
I didn't,
uh,
didn't look forward to it ending.
He didn't bring your phone with,
you know,
well,
it doesn't work.
There's no,
there's no cell phone reception out there.
Nothing.
You can't get anything out there.
But I knew that going in there and
it was what I was thinking was like,
this is going to be an
interesting opportunity to
sorta get off the grid for a
little bit and see what that feels like.
And one of the weird things about getting
off the grid for a few days is that,
um,
he got a lot of energy,
man,
got a lot of energy when you're walking
around going after these deer and then
in between your role and your bone.
But even when you sit
down for a few minutes,
you don't,
you're not exhausted.
You don't want to take a nap.
Like you have energy.
It's like,
dude,
I think that's what people are
supposed to be smart phones.
People were supposed to be working
and doing things physically all day.
And when they don't do
things physically all day,
they get exhausted.
I really believe that.
I think if you look at our
past as when we developed,
you know,
to the back the time where people
just first started storing foods and
developing clothes and making weapons
and figuring out how to hunt animals.
We were in motion all day where there
were a building shelter or collecting
food.
We were in motion all day
and I think that's how our,
that's our default.
And when we sit down like at a desk and
you're sitting in front of a computer or
you're sitting there and you know,
just sitting in front of the
TV in front of Television,
I think your body gets confused as fuck.
I think your body's like,
well,
we're just not moving.
So I guess we should.
Oh like,
well why would that be a reason?
It's just not eating.
That's why I think that being in front
of a computer or being in a cubicle,
like doing that all day,
like sitting in a desk all day is
probably terrible for your body.
Terrible for you brain.
How do we do this and
fucking surf the web.
We should go walk even this right now.
Like we're not doing anything.
Yeah,
but we're having a conversation.
You know,
this is the best way to have
a conversation is in the,
in a way that you don't have
to think about your body.
You know,
you shut it off and relax.
We were standing up,
you know,
we wouldn't be having as cool of a
conversation because we would be,
maybe we should try it.
We're not walking podcasts where we just
go for a nice walk and it's a bad idea.
This
was worse because with this fucking sucks.
I want to go play Pokemon.
Okay.
Mine is this first thing that came to me.
Um,
is there a um,
like a thing that we could get like the
big foot got hunter guys do a podcast
videos of us getting
monitoring around Pasa.
Dena,
look,
you do a blog.
We could totally do that.
Yeah.
That's a good idea.
Well to this too pretentious
about Griffith Park,
we would find people that will like put
their resumes in front of the fucking
camera,
such filled with so many
fucking douche bags.
Yeah,
we should totally do that.
I took a lot of photos.
Let's go to the zoo.
I took a lot of photos from this trip.
I'll kick a lot of photos
of their animal and uh,
I mean I showed you a picture
of the animal that a shot,
but so what happened was on the third day
was when we were,
um,
we were,
we had gone hiking through
the morning and then we,
uh,
went and looked for deer.
We didn't,
we didn't see anything.
We got,
we saw a couple of weeks and get close
enough to them to get a shot at him.
And then,
uh,
we rode for a few miles down the river
and then we stopped at this one place.
And uh,
we're,
we traveled about a
mile in this long field.
We're going up all these hills and
one of the director's spots is deer.
So there's just one dear.
That's all is.
And he's director,
was he like,
actually no,
no,
no director had the,
the director also his works
as a camera man and his name,
his name is Manuel.
This is a super hard job.
It's a for a TV show,
104 television show.
Oh really?
Yeah.
I can't wait to see what,
it's all full documentation.
A lot of funny moments.
Oh yeah.
My God.
So much fun.
Cause Callen went with me
so they had a hike with,
with all their,
all their cameras and shit
while they hold a camera.
They have a camera that's not light.
Okay.
These guys are in serious shape.
Mo Is this a,
the directors is big
strapping guy and he fucking,
he's huffing it man.
I mean this is a real work.
And Rinella,
the guy just started the show.
He does this shit all year round.
So he's in serious shape
like he's in really like,
there's like a type of shape
that you get in for hiking.
Like it's a hiking shape and
he's in like great hiking shape.
And so,
uh,
he takes these really perilous pass too.
It was like,
a lot of times I was like,
Whoa,
this is like tricky shit because I'm
carrying a rifle and I'm carrying a rifle
and we're climbing up mountains and it's,
it's,
you know,
it was no joke,
man.
We did it.
We did the whole thing the right way.
I mean it wasn't,
there was,
there was this was like a
hundred percent wild animal.
Most likely this deer had never
seen a person before was yeah,
we,
I mean we were in the
bad lands of Montana.
It was like some serious shit,
right.
So we were getting over the
top of this Ridge and we,
uh,
we look over and most easiest steer so
we have to creep up on it and we have to
creep up on it and go up wind
of it or downwind rather.
So that it's,
it's sent is coming to
us and ours is coming in.
And so then,
uh,
we've got a shot off at it,
um,
at 200 yards.
I shot it from 200 yards.
You killed it.
How did they,
how did you know how to use
the rifle the right way?
He showed me how,
showed me how to days before.
It was pretty simple.
I,
I shot guns before you
standing up or lying down,
lying down,
lying down on the ground.
He had a scope and everything,
you have to correct scope
because it was 200 yards away.
Bullets.
The gravity hits them so they'll
go down the further or so.
You have to know to aim slightly up if
you're 50 yards away or 300 yards away
and they get,
the scope is designed for that.
Yeah.
It tells you how far not for,
not for high powered rifles.
It takes a long time before they,
they change trajectory that goes
pretty straight for a long time.
I mean it's like a really serious rifle.
Um,
so the deer drops and I
didn't even know he dropped.
Like I shoot it,
the whole thing.
It's a really tricky thing
like shooting something.
First of all you're breathing.
I'm breathing heavy.
Like we had,
you know,
done all this crazy hiking
and my adrenaline is fine
cause I'm trying to relax
and tune in and I don't
want to hurt this thing.
I want to shoot it in the leg and it runs
away and we can never catch it again.
And you know,
you know what I mean?
And bleeds out.
I wanted to just,
I wanted to do it correctly,
so I wanted to make sure that I had a
good shot and I dropped it with the first
shot.
He wasn't dead.
Um,
I had to kill it.
I had to drop it,
hit it with a c.
No he was,
he was going to die.
It shot him through like right above,
uh,
like his heart.
And so it would have taken,
he like hit his spine or we
Amy for the heart of the head.
He aimed for the heart.
And so then you have to walk up to it
or shot it again and write their shot it
from a distance.
How far was pretty close?
I got,
I got pretty close to make sure that I
didn't miss 10 feet no further than that.
Like 20 with the rifle again
with the rifle and then I,
I finished it.
It was a,
it was very intense man.
Cause then right after that then we're,
we're gutting it and it's hot.
Okay.
You know,
you know,
and I made,
I made like a real conscious decision
to do this and I know I got a lot of
criticism from a lot of people
that said you shouldn't go hunting.
You shouldn't kill something.
This is like so hard.
But here's,
here's the issue.
And it's like a lot of these people that
I'm talking to you that were in leather
shoes,
okay,
you got leather in your car,
interior,
you know,
you eat burgers and you've
got no problem with it.
You,
my shop until they find out
the iPhone is made of one.
Um,
this is my point of view
and I don't want it,
it's not that I want to kill animals.
I'm like a mean person.
I want to out and,
and kill these,
these beautiful animals.
But I eat meat and uh,
I've eaten meat my whole life and I've
taken no responsibility for how that meat
is acquired.
I,
I read all this shit
about farming and I don't,
I don't want to be attached to that.
I don't,
I don't want to be attached
to be to factory farming.
Yeah.
And means a huge difference.
I don't want to be attached to,
uh,
to these,
these,
the way they treat animals where they,
you know,
they essentially have them
live their entire lives,
tortured in cages,
feeding shit food that their body can't
even digest to fatten them up and then
then we kill them and eat them and then
you just pick it up at the supermarket.
Completely detached from the process.
It just is meat,
you know?
And so I,
I knew coming in that this is
going to be a weird experience.
Like how was I going to address this?
What was I going to,
was I going to,
um,
like was I going to enjoy this?
Was I going to feel terrible
and become a vegetarian?
Wha How was my reaction to
it when you walked up to her,
how'd you feel when it was dead
before you shot the second time?
I have to kill it.
You could see it close enough to know.
It's like actually breathing
and stuff with your hearing.
Yeah.
You can hear it.
What was he doing?
Just struggling.
Yeah,
I'm struggling.
Who wasn't moving much?
I mean,
he like,
he was going to die soon,
but I had to make sure that I
took care of it right there.
And,
um,
it's,
look,
it's uh,
it's very strange.
The whole,
the whole experience is very strange.
The whole experience of,
of tracking them down a strange knowing
that you're tracking them down to
eventually eat them,
you know?
And then when you're actually eating it,
it's like,
you know,
that that night we sat around the campfire
and we cooked liver and the heart and
the kidneys.
Did you get it backwards?
You can't fair?
No,
we had to,
we had to bring it back.
How'd you carry it back?
You've cut it up,
cut it up first and
everyone's texted pace.
Well,
we did the first night.
We took the,
the,
the organs out that we
could use that you'd eat.
You don't eat all the organs,
which you eat the liver and eat
the heart and you eat the kidneys.
And so we took all that stuff.
What have you,
or the rest of the word we,
um,
we pulled it out and we were
going to use it for cat fish bait,
but you just leave it there and we want
to believing it there and other animals.
We eat it.
Yeah.
Like almost immediately the ravens were
find it and when the ravens find it,
then the,
the coyotes,
we'll figure out where the ravens
are and the coyotes will go to there.
It's like nature has us really
efficient system of cleaning out.
Yeah.
So it's really amazing.
So we leave the Oregons um,
take the edible organs and then leave
the body overnight because it takes a few
hours to part it up and okay.
To clean it and parking lot.
No,
it's 30 degrees outside,
so it's like,
okay.
A frigerator.
So you tie it up to make sure
that nothing can get to it,
but there's no insects there.
Everything's
warm.
You couldn't have done that or what's,
what's the deal?
Can,
you know you couldn't do that?
You can't leave the meat
out if it's hot out.
Like,
if it's in Texas in August,
you should have your hat like
that because they always kill it.
It doesn't like go straight to her fridge.
That's a good question.
I don't know how long you have some time,
but if it's hot out,
you don't have as much time.
That's when people sell
things to preserve them,
right?
Yeah.
But that's uh,
you know,
that's not what they do with wild game.
That's what they used to
do with meat back then.
I didn't have refrigerators.
I don't really totally
understand how that works either,
but maybe bacteria doesn't live on the
surface with the salt or something.
I don't know.
But um,
so it was so cold out.
We just left it there.
You can leave it there.
It's like leaving in the fridgerator
and then wa it was like a mile from the
camp.
So then we had to walk back from the camp.
Kenyon k yeah.
We had to take it apart.
How much of that,
how much that buck way or
it was about 180 pounds.
180 pounds.
So you guys had to just put that up.
Yeah.
We had to chop it out
at 40 14 carried out.
Yeah,
it was a lot of work.
That was a,
that was the most difficult
than was carrying the,
uh,
the,
the uh,
buck back.
I actually know,
you know,
all the hiking together,
all of it was pretty hard.
It was the really slippery slopes
are probably the hardest thing,
but the most difficult thing is staying
calm and shooting the animal and then
making a decision.
Like,
is this really what you want to do?
Like what do you do?
You've already made that decision.
But I wanted to know,
I wanted to look the,
the detachment that a normal
person has an eats meat.
I don't necessarily think that's healthy.
I think that we have,
uh,
we've removed what it is from our
heads and we're just acquiring meat.
We're just going to a
supermarket and acquiring meat.
And uh,
I think that that lack of connection.
I don't know.
I think ultimately it's not,
it's not healthy and I
think it's not natural.
I think it's weird.
It's like being in the,
know where the food comes from.
It's like being born rich or something,
you know?
It's like you don't,
you don't really appreciate
it or understand it.
What do you mean they're just grab
food that somebody else killed?
They killed things too,
dude.
They're out there.
That's a hard scrabble life.
You can't be picky and
choosy when your coyote,
but I mean is that like the idea of
going to a supermarket and everything's
prayer prepared and packaged for
you about shots of the animal?
Like a photo of me when I was,
maybe this is me at one years old,
just learn how to walk.
I feel like now when you
buy the meat you won't,
you'll put up appreciate it more.
Well,
I have a lot of deer meat
to eat and that that,
oh yeah,
did you like it?
You like,
it's delicious.
The best meat you can eat.
So now they say you want to get it clean
so it doesn't taste the game because it
released that testosterone or
whatever it is for adrenaline.
Once you hit it before you kill it.
Yeah,
they're going to have
adrenaline no matter what,
man.
I mean,
if it doesn't die instantly,
but it doesn't taste bad,
you know,
it's,
it's a really lean,
delicious meat.
It tastes,
it tastes really good.
Um,
for a lot of people,
they have a problem with killing things.
I,
I get it.
You eat meat but you
don't like killing things.
And I understand that.
But I think,
uh,
being upset at someone,
be upset,
being upset at someone for
killing something that they eat,
I think it's a little bit hypocritical,
not a little bit
ridiculously hypocritical.
It's,
and it's also a stupid,
it's,
we're,
we're not being honest about what our,
as,
as an organism,
we're not being honest
about what we are as an organism.
If you're mad at people that hunt,
because every fucking
restaurant you go to,
ever way you look has
murdered animals in it.
That's everywhere.
You learn something different though,
to be part of the killing as opposed to
being okay with the killing going on.
He's like,
you don't want to be an execution
or where you can believe in capital
punishment.
Yeah.
Gas If you weren't eating the prisoners,
FTA killed them.
But I'm saying you don't have
to be the one doing the killing.
Yeah.
Difference between doing the killing
and just being okay with people were
getting murdered.
I don't think the capital punishment
argument works because you don't need
capital punishment for sustenance.
You need,
you know,
you don't need meat either
as people that exist.
I'm being a vegetarian,
but if you're consuming me,
you're eating it and you know
that is a part of your diet.
That's your part of your everyday dot.
Yet we have no connection with that
and that was the issue that I had.
I was like,
man,
I feel like I just as a human
going through this life,
if I'm going to continue to eat meat,
I should take apart in the process.
I don't want to start a farm
and go kill a pig on a farm.
No part of you want to just
go to a photo farm insight.
Let's just do that.
Why?
When I think the best way is this animal
lives at totally natural wildlife and
then boom,
it gets shot.
Can just make an argument for them.
Cause I think it's fine.
I don't care at all,
but uh,
that deer would not have died.
You don't know that you're wrong.
Most of them,
most of them die.
Either they get killed by predators
or they die because it gets cold out.
That happens.
It's out eventually,
but when it died right then,
but if you go to a farm,
but there's killing cows
that that would have died,
right then just you're doing it.
Wouldn't that be more of
taking apart in the process?
I don't know what you're saying.
Go to a farm where they're
killing a bunch of cows.
Today's CALC Killam Day go there and say,
Hey,
let me work there.
The deliver for a little bit.
Let me fuck it.
Put a nail gun in his head.
Well,
you know what?
That's like a semantics argument.
Like why would you even care?
You're killing.
You're taking a life either way.
Take a life that's destined to
be taken and it's less work.
It's less.
Less mean.
If that's a normal kind of meet people
eat then that seems like if you're
sending you wondering where deer
is as normal as eating cows,
well first of all to one,
people don't eat there as much
to if they do where they have it.
If they do eat meat,
they usually get it from
supermarkets which are farmed today.
Today we want to take human history.
People have been eating deer.
I mean if you're saying you want to take
a part of what you're eating and say
I'm going to take uh,
uh,
I'm going to let my conscious sit on
this and see this is what we're doing and
what you want to go and do actually what
you're doing to get that meat and not
change it to a different way.
I'm not sure I follow you.
If you get your chicken from farms
that killed 3000 chickens in a day,
and that's where people get that chicken.
Wouldn't it be better if you want to see
what it's actually like where there's
checking comes from,
would it be better to go to a place like
that where the count chickens all day
and have it strong up
and sliced his throat,
then killing a while checking,
um,
without them.
If you are dead set on
eating factory raise chicken,
I could see your point.
But if your point was that you want it
to be a part of what you ate that not
that you specifically wanted
to eat factory raise chicken.
Yeah.
You know what I'm saying?
Like I think that the idea of an animal
living a wild life and then it's life
ending in a brief moment because a bullet.
Yeah,
I think that is a more humane and more,
I don't even like the word
humane because humane.
What?
What is the actual
meaning of humane cause?
Is it because humans,
I don't think you're so fucking humane.
Technically we've,
if you look at how we acquire,
that's not all right
then we're going to farm.
They would have died then.
So it's like you can take
apart without adding to the,
to a kill.
I see what you're saying,
but it doesn't make sense.
I think you're just begged,
begged,
but it totally makes sense
that I see what you're saying.
You want to show that you're a part
of this and they'll work counseling.
Most of you know,
I want it there.
I also want to eat game.
I could gain the best food.
I think,
um,
I've,
I've said this for a long time that I
think that there's probably more nutrition
and wild game than any other kind of food.
And I think that that's one of the
reasons why they're so elusive.
They know that they're
worth something dear.
When the deer hears you and those fucking
intendant ears pop up and they start
looking at,
they know that they're like
super nutritious and there's
a bunch of animals out
there that are just trying to jack them.
They used to be a lot more mountain lions,
but apparently they have a
good healthy supply of them.
Now.
We didn't see any while we were there,
but whenever you have a lot of deer,
you have a lot of mountain lions
because that's where the three,
yeah,
that's what they eat.
Especially Fonz.
They'll go after the babies because
they're easy and they could take them and
that kind of made sure to set everything
up work because everything sort of a
fighting chance.
We're not going to kill you,
but the ones that are too bold
and go out away from the herd,
you're going to get jack.
It's very fascinating to be,
even though I went there with all these
human inventions like tents and guns and
all that stuff,
to be out there living in
nature for four or five days,
it's so far very eyeopening experience,
man.
There's some weird,
some weird primal shit goes off when
you're out there stalking a deer that
you're eventually going to eat.
And then like later that night you're
sitting in front of a campfire with a
bunch of men and everyone's feasting on
the meat from this animal and talking
about how delicious it is and enjoying it.
And it's very strange,
man.
It's,
it's,
it's a lot.
I can see where a lot of people
would be uncomfortable with it.
I could see where a lot of people
would be angry and you know,
they might be a little bit of rational
and be pissed at me that I went and w and
I hunted.
But you know,
you're not,
you're not mad at me when
I have a cheeseburger,
you know,
there's not,
I don't get cries for an anger when I
put a steak on the grill and take a photo
of it,
which I do all the time because I like
to cook steaks like two o'clock in the
morning like a boss.
What happens if you didn't
find that dude that day?
We have no idea.
I got to keep looking.
No,
we ate this fridge,
freeze dried foods.
We ate these freeze dried meals.
The like you opened them up and you pour
hot water on them and they had these
jets,
these flame jets that would boil water
and you turn the flame jets on and you
put this water canister over and it'll
boil the water and the water starts
boiling and you shut it off.
And then you pour the boiling water into
the bag and you seal it and you let it
sit for a few minutes and it's not bad.
You know,
they have like,
like you're boil the water over.
Cause he saw that shit on Amazon,
like a huge carton of
just tons of those packs,
the right stuff.
You know,
like if we go,
we need that.
You'd be amazed at like,
you could actually survive off of it.
It's not bad.
It actually tastes pretty good.
So you see,
the only thing that was was
ruthless is the sleeping outside.
It's just,
that's really difficult to get used to.
And the,
uh,
the physical activity of stocking the
animal and then the reality of the
shooting of the animal,
that that was intense because I wondered
how it was gonna feel about that.
I wonder if I was going to feel
sad if I'm going to feel bad,
but I didn't feel bad.
Yeah.
When I felt it felt very natural.
And when you're eating it,
when you're thinking about the animal,
you're killed.
It really,
we're just enjoying a good,
well,
I was enjoying it.
I was thinking about the process in which,
uh,
you know,
it happened.
I was thinking about it's life.
You know,
I,
I felt,
uh,
I mean it sounds very cliche to say
you feel very connected with nature,
but man,
that is the perfect description.
It's like being connected with nature,
you know,
and like,
you don't have to eat nature
to be connected with it.
I know,
but guess what,
folks,
when we eat Broccoli,
you're,
you're eating nature.
You're fuck,
okay.
When you eat celery,
you're eating nature.
You know,
when you eat beets,
you're eating a living part of nature.
It's just can't,
it can't defend itself.
It doesn't scream,
it doesn't try to run away.
So you assume it's okay.
It's not the same species as us.
But we would be super excited
if we found that on Mars.
Okay.
If we found Kale on Mars and you know,
and in some asshole
came around and ate it,
fucking Mars,
Kale,
you can't,
this is life from another
planet and you ate it.
It's Mars Fed.
It gets so regular though.
He,
and it doesn't mean that I didn't
think that the animal was beautiful.
I thought the animals very beautiful.
I'm amazed just to see them.
I enjoyed seeing all the
rams that we couldn't shoot.
We couldn't get tagged to shoot them,
but I enjoyed seeing them.
But I think that ideally I would
like to eat nothing but game meat.
I think that'd be the best for me,
like health wise.
And I think that it would be the most
honest way to be a mediator and the,
so that's what I'm going to try to do.
And we're going to go again in the
summer and we'd go hunting for Caribou.
Carolyn's going to go again,
eat those things.
Yeah,
they're huge.
And so you're going to have
stuff shipped in from now on?
Yeah.
My,
my meat is in,
um,
is in Montana.
It's on its way to me.
They freeze it and they send it.
I don't know.
I mean it.
What's your like from like more often
I'm going to do this more often.
Yeah.
I'm going to do,
I'm going to try to go
hunting a couple times a year.
Can you just buy game meat?
You could,
you could do that too,
but you,
what you'd be buying is the animals,
but they'd be like in a farm situation
and you'd have to make sure that they
were grass fed.
You would want to make sure I don't
have a wild game that you can,
you can buy.
No,
no,
I don't think you're
allowed to sell wild game.
Oh,
real.
Yeah.
I think you have to,
it has to be domesticated.
I think I could be wrong about that.
It might be different
in each state as well.
There's a very big,
any difference.
I know
a fresh water fish,
I think tastes better the
quicker you get it to the pan.
Yeah,
but I'm salt water,
not as much of a problem is or
does it any freshness factor to it?
Like,
well,
the Oregon's,
yes.
You should cook the Oregons
quickly as possible.
The organs and delicious
like dear liver is fantastic.
He's better right then.
Then a day later,
yeah,
you don't want it,
but the,
the meat actually is a,
according to Steve.
Grinnell is better the next day.
It gives you the chance to relax and uh,
you know,
it's,
it's a very,
you muscular animal,
so you have to prepare in a certain,
yeah,
it's very little fat.
They're incredibly lean.
So when you cook them,
you have to make sure that
you don't over cook it.
You Cook it really quickly and uh,
either you have it very much on the rare
side you can really venison venison.
Yeah.
Or You could slow cook it.
That's the other way too,
where it breaks it down
like a pork shoulder.
You know,
they do that,
they slow cook it.
Um,
so we'll wind up,
um,
I'll figure out,
you know,
how to,
how to cook all of it.
Well.
Yeah,
but I have like,
that's probably like 60
or 70,000 pounds of meat.
We rename you think all our meats.
We don't do it with birds,
but all our meats we renamed.
You don't have to talk
about the animal that it is.
Probably like venison and yeah.
Yeah.
Cow Becomes damn fork steer becomes beef.
It's a,
it's weird.
W A steer,
you know we have too many of steer.
What's that?
Oh,
that's a cow that we cut his nuts off.
No,
he doesn't do it there.
He was at bowl at one point in time,
but we're like,
yeah,
you're not going to need those dudes.
You're,
you're here for steak.
I really need you that sinewy.
Yeah,
I guess you can't eat a bolt,
you know?
I don't know.
I mean,
we don't want them to have their
balls because I think they get like
rambunctious.
Yeah.
I don't think squeeze the ball's
been bull riding contests then.
Yeah.
I don't know about that.
That's what I've heard.
They asked me to go on
celebrity Rodeo once.
I was like,
bitch.
Yeah.
I was like,
are you Outta your mind?
And go into any more with a bowl.
You crazy bull riding.
It's celebrity bull riding and I was like,
you are,
you're out of your mind.
I think Stephen Baldwin did it
in a couple of other people.
I'm like,
yeah,
it's asking for your body
to be broken forever.
Not even getting stomped on just
the throne from a bull dude.
You know,
nobody rides a bull successfully.
It's just a matter of how long
before you get thrown off.
So if you,
you know,
you can,
that's what you have to deal with.
It's the best thing.
You write it out so it runs out of energy.
Then you just write a so stupid on it.
Riding a boast.
So ridiculous.
How,
um,
how,
what was the feeling like
after you're killing,
you're frying it up or whatever.
Strange.
No,
but like the feeling of being able
to talk fully for the first time.
Could you,
could you talk then or were you still,
we talked to on the campfire,
we always talked around
the campfire at night.
Will,
you know,
which just while we're walking around,
we're trying to be pretty quiet.
Was that relieving every night to be
able to like actually use your voice?
No,
we really able to talk.
Yeah,
there was a little bit of that.
Yeah.
It was nice to go at camp and fuck around.
The guys were really nice guys.
This Guy Steve Rinella,
he's got a great group of dudes
that he's got working for him.
He really,
really put together an awesome crew and
they have to be bad motherfuckers cause
out there freezing their dicks off,
sleeping in tents and for them,
you know,
this is their job for me,
it was like some crazy vacation and an
opportunity to go hunting for the first
time and you know and
do this dude's TV show.
Hey Buddy.
But for um,
for these guys that the
camera man and the director,
that's just an everyday
part of their life.
That's what they do every day.
I mean that's a fucking tough job man.
You camping outside most of the year,
you know,
always campus
constantly.
They're constantly camp and
the camp camping in Montana,
the camp in an Arizona film,
that stuff that camping
all over the phone.
This is a show that's already on?
Yeah,
it's been awhile.
It's called meat eater.
Oh yeah.
The dude had a show on the travel channel
called the wild within and it was a
good show.
It was like a really great choice show.
What's it for hunting you sort of,
yeah.
I mean like one of the things he did
was he hunted Moose the same way,
Louis or a,
um,
a buffalo the same way
Lewis and Clark did.
He shot a bison with a musket,
but all we're going old school must get
killed it and then turned it into a boat
the same way they would back then where
they would make like a boat out of these
things and,
and take it into I boats.
Yeah,
he did that on the show.
It was pretty interesting fucking show.
I really enjoyed it.
He's like a real wild west historian.
Like he told us some crazy fucking stories
about different things at the Indians
had done to the white man.
The white man had done to the Indians.
And one dude,
um,
his,
uh,
he,
he gave up,
but his friend tried to resist,
so they took his friend,
they butchered him in front
of them and cut them open.
Yeah.
They cut his dick off and they rubbed it
all over his friend cut his lungs off,
rubbed all his friends,
and then they told them,
we're going to give you a headstart and
then we're going to come and kill you.
And so this guy out random,
and he outran them and jumped into
the river and hid in a beaver den.
They have beaver dens everywhere.
And the beaver dens.
What it is essentially is it's like
the water's running there and this guy
climbed under the water and into a hole
that the beavers had dug into the side
of the river bank so they can eat,
breathe in there.
So he laid in there and
waited until the Indians left.
And then he walked a hundred miles down
to the nearest town and barefoot and
naked.
And uh,
he ate a rattlesnake and
he ate a piece of just raw.
Yep.
And a piece of buffalo
that he found as he was,
uh Oh wait,
so the Indians killed his friend in front
of this group just to be more like me
up just to,
you know,
cause the guy resisted,
who was this the guy that kills two guys?
Yeah.
There was all these stories about what
happened when the Indians ran into each
other.
You know what's also fascinating,
what he told me it was him,
how ruthless the Indians were to
each other or the native Americans,
you should say each other.
Like they were fucking checking
each other left and right.
In fact,
there was some that were near the,
in the Great Lakes area that
we're practicing cannibalism of.
Other tribes are on a regular basis.
They were eating them for food.
You know that like,
I mean it was like,
imagine how harsh it must've been around
the great lakes like in the winter,
like how brutal that shit is.
And I,
I guess some of the natives that
were were hearing each other,
we're ruthless and they actually
want up cannibalizing people.
Yeah.
Eating people that were,
you know,
travelers for the cowboys.
Do Bat.
Oh really?
Just like traveling by people.
Yeah,
man,
you fuck up.
You ride your fucking wagon.
Train to the wrong town.
This town is a,
with these guys at that eat people
cause that liquor we have for Compton.
No.
[inaudible] we're blue in
certain areas or by accident.
It's way nicer now than it was
in the American Indian days.
Can you imagine how ruthless,
I mean,
look,
there's one thing to
run it a gang warfare,
but I mean bands of people
that want to eat you.
He gets like,
I saw one saw me from 400
miles away at 400 yards away.
I got to kill them or we're all dead.
Yeah.
Custer's last stand he
was describing like,
he's like,
he's like a real historian Steven Rinella
guy and he's just like talking about
all the things that happened
during custards last days.
One of the things they did was they
mutilated all the bodies the Indians did
after they killed customers.
Men so that they would have a shitty
afterlife like to cut his dick off so we
can't use in the afterlife,
cut his legs apart.
He can't use his legs
at that point anymore.
Arms out,
punctured his ears,
stabbed his ears so he could,
uh,
he could listen to warnings better
in the afterlife and the wow.
Yeah.
Cause they warned him that this
was going to happen to him.
Yeah,
it's crazy.
And what's really crazy,
there was a guy named
Gaul and a big giant,
big giant Indian dude that was involved
in the massacre of Custer's last stand.
And he was involved in killing customers,
men.
And after it was over,
he went on those wild bill's wild west
tours where they would show up in towns
and they would say,
this is gall.
He's responsible for killing,
you know,
over 500 men.
And the guy would like be standing
there like sneering at people.
And he really was,
he really was the guy that killed
custard in his man and very was you could
watch him.
I mean,
he was free to just be
walking around and he,
you know,
he was a part of a war and when the war
was over and he hung out with wild bill
and they took him around,
I mean,
could you imagine that
I could live in you?
Imagine if they did that with
like EDI mean or some water load.
Yeah.
Some warlord was on some,
uh,
some show guys relax.
I kill that.
That couple hundred thousand people.
Saddam Hussein was one
day on one of these,
uh,
these,
it would definitely like celebrity
apprentice and shit like that.
Yeah.
Wow.
Imagine he would do
those celebrity survivor.
That's the future.
That's when the,
our civilization really
goes into the shitter.
Yeah.
Wait a minute.
Why?
Instead of,
let's seriously,
instead of killing tree,
I know this is like running man shit,
but instead of killing Charles
Taylor and fucking sad,
almost saying all these people,
why not have like a let him
fucking running man and out,
uh,
why just feel so it's entertaining.
Yeah.
Hmm.
Well that's what we cash off.
That's when we get dangerously immoral
and they're like,
this guy littered and
they get him in there.
What if we can hunt abortion?
So somehow with like how make it give
them a fighting chance if you get shrunk
down.
So you're in there with,
with the woman inner space abortions.
God,
could you imagine talking
to you while you in there?
Don't do that.
It's like you just have a wonderful line.
Father
is already creeped out.
Hey,
did you have it?
Did you,
when you walked up to kill it till
after you were like punctured it,
did you have any thought of like,
I should say a snappy
like Supergirl lives?
I'd like hell,
you're going upside down and you're like,
no,
it's so,
it's,
so a lot of that before
moment is so,
uh,
like it's so sober.
You know the one moment you just shot
an animal for the first time and he
dropped it and seen it flop onto its back
with its legs up in the air and it was
like trying to get up,
but he couldn't get up.
It was done.
You didn't think to say,
I guess the buck stops here.
What does the dude's name dude from Miami?
CSI.
What's that sound?
Oh God.
I guess the buck stops here.
You son of a bitch.
How did
it wasn't,
it wasn't funny at all.
Why did you decide who gets the shot?
It was me.
I was,
I had,
uh,
the show I was with about and
Brian Cowen was off with a,
another,
uh,
professional hunting guide.
And Brian also was getting filmed with a
different camera because you can't have
that many people out hunting.
Deciding which animal did his go well,
yeah,
yeah.
He got,
he shot an animal to meet up at night.
Yeah.
We made up at night.
You knew of the a plots?
Yeah,
we met up what?
We had a camping spot and then we would
go hiking and they would come back to
the camp spot and then
we would row together.
So we would talk shit while we're rowing
down the river together and make jokes.
Like Brian Callan is one of the perfect
human vans to go on any long trip like
that.
Cause he's so fucking
hilarious and he's never off.
He's never off.
He's on the whole time.
And it was a series of gay jokes
that never ended or evolve,
but they,
they,
they got more and more
hilarious until the end of it.
It was sick.
While we're,
I mean this sounds like so disrespectful,
but while we're like butchering
the deer in between it Kaolin
Oh,
does this thing where he starts,
stands over the ravine and starts
masturbating into the ravine.
Just,
just comes up with it.
They call me the ravine comer.
Yeah.
That's what I do.
I find a ravine all,
I can't help calming.
I'm coming into the world doing this.
It was just,
it was so ridiculous.
He doesn't have to be
able to use that down.
We're going to put it on the Internet.
We're going to put it on the Internet
because it was so ridiculous.
It has to go on the Internet.
He had his tongue out and he was like
making this fucking like really aggressive
face and just shoot
pretending to shoot loads over the ravine.
It was so,
it was so silly and so hilarious.
You,
but it was also in stark contrast
to what we're doing at the time,
which was butchering this animal.
You know?
When I gutted it,
that was,
that was the really intense part because
it was just a few moments after I shot
it and then all of a sudden I'm cutting
it open and as I'm cutting it open steam
is coming out.
It's like a Tauntaun.
Yes.
It's,
well not quite so bad,
but very close and it's,
it's really,
really warm.
They,
their bodies are warmer than ours.
Their bodies like 104
degrees or something like,
oh yeah,
man will not warm him up.
I had a pull the organs out that
they all have you slide to fall out.
Yeah.
You have to,
you have to slice it a certain way.
You have to slice around the body and
like pull it all the way up to the neck
and then you have to cut through
the rib cage with a hatchet.
Yeah.
It's serious shit,
man.
Is that your first time?
Like you never did any kind of like
butcher snow knows it's fucking serious
shit.
Like,
you know when you're eating a piece of
meat from an animal that you saw bouncing
around and then you put a bullet into
him and then you go and open them up and
take his organs out and then section his
body off and then cook it and eat it.
Like there is no confusion as to where
that meat came from and there's a
complete direct attachment I'd say.
Then it becomes sorry,
but then it becomes sort
of a philosophical debate.
Like is that what you want to do?
Do you want to just kill nature natural
animals and eat them or do you want to
just remain to be a part of this sort of
strange disconnect system where we are
all getting meat and not even thinking
for a second that that used to be an
animal.
We have like no intellectual connection
with the idea that that was a lot of it
came from,
yeah,
we just eat it.
You know,
and especially we eat this
really unhealthy stuff.
I'm not even close.
It doesn't even make sense.
It's,
it's weird to fucking weird,
you know,
I'm not,
it's a neon outside
that while you were all,
you're like eating,
this is like going through your mind.
No,
because while we can,
I would just be like,
this is delicious.
Why was he getting it?
I was thinking this delicious,
but it was also thinking,
man,
this is like,
this is a serious thing
that just happened,
you know?
And I got to treat this
serious thing with,
uh,
with respect.
And someone said on my message board
wants that hunting was psychedelic,
that he felt hunting with psychedelic.
And I was like,
well,
that's ridiculous.
It sounds like,
it sounds like,
it sounds like you don't
know what psychedelic means,
you know?
That's what I was thinking.
Like how could that be psychedelic?
That's like the opposite.
It's like adult,
like you're like killing
an animal and you're,
you're taking a life.
But then in doing it,
I think I didn't know what he meant or,
or what,
what it could mean.
What psychedelic about it is that you,
you are in a totally different world
when you're there and you're in nature.
Okay.
And there's no cell
phone signal and shows,
no radio,
there's no media.
Nothing is is in in front of you except
nature and you're walking around in it
all day looking for an animal and then
when you finally lock on to that and
you're doing this for days and days and
he finally lock on to that animal and
then you take that animal's life and
you see it and you become a part of this
experience,
then eat this thing.
You realize like Whoa,
all of a sudden like I am in the wild.
Like I am literally immersed in the wild.
I have just slept in the wild aid,
an animal that I shot in the wild,
killed it in the wild,
cooked it in the wild on some trees.
We chop some wood and we made a
campfire and cooked it over at Campfire.
I mean it is as wildlife
immersive as is possible.
And when that happens,
man,
it's a real paradigm shifting moment and
much like in a psychedelic experience
after it's over,
you go,
wow,
I am going to take as much of that I can
take with me and that's going to make
me a better person.
That's gonna make me a more honest person.
That's gonna I,
this is certainly a powerful experience.
I'm going to grow from it.
I think about that almost every
time I trip or have tripped.
And that's exactly how I felt about this.
And in that way,
it's sort of psychedelic.
Did you trip it all while you were there?
Like a mustache?
No.
Freaked out.
No,
no.
I wouldn't have freaked out,
but that's,
there's no,
there was no time to fuck around.
I mean,
this was a,
it was,
uh,
it was a difficult endeavor.
The way he does it.
It's,
you don't have time to like go do
mushrooms and lie around the grass for six
hours.
You're up wandering through
the hills of the rifle.
And if I had cotton all the way there
with them and then decided to just do
mushrooms,
they'll be like so disrespectful to
show and so disrespectful to what he's
trying to do because when he's
trying to do is with his show,
he's trying to do these really difficult
and challenging hunts and he took me
along to do it exactly the way he does it,
you know?
So I had to do it the way he does.
Picture this picture of this.
You've got that on day three.
I don't have a feeling it's
going to be a gang question.
You and Karen,
you're on Brokeback mountain.
Beautiful.
Uh,
okay.
You get this thing on day three,
you're back to your last campsite.
You still have a day and a half left,
right?
You're like,
okay,
we did it.
That's amazing.
Come and come to terms with that stuff
and you're undoing your sleeping bag and
stuff.
You're like,
yeah,
actually where my code is actually cold.
And you reached in your pocket like,
Oh fuck hey guys,
I forgot these written here.
I just found these mushrooms,
which do him then.
MMM.
That's interesting.
Everybody could do all the problem is,
um,
I would want to not be incapacitated
in case something went wrong.
He never know what could go
wrong when you're camping,
you know the idea that you're just going
to sit there and you'd do the mushrooms
for five hours and you'll be fine.
That sounds good in theory.
However you need eight hours sleep and
you really got to make sure you get that
cause you got a hard day ahead of you.
And second of all,
there's no five hour breaks there
between the light being off,
eating your food and then
sleeping for eight hours,
then getting up while it's still dark out,
there's really not,
there's no time to do it.
So I wouldn't have done it because
there was still work to be done.
I still had to go back up there and get
the deer itself and cut it apart and
that stuff takes hours.
It wasn't easy,
you know.
Oh you went back.
Yeah.
So there was no time to do mushrooms
and then the next morning Brian got his.
So,
uh,
he helped me go and get my dear and cut
it up and that's when he was jerking off
into the sea.
He call himself the ravine calmer.
But um,
yeah,
it was,
the whole experience was
a very surreal from the,
from pulling the trigger to watch
the animal fall into its back.
It's very surreal to,
you know,
ending its life,
to cutting it open and to eating it.
It's pretty fucking intense man.
And I think that's the most
honest way to get food.
I really do.
I think that's the most
honest way to get meat.
I'm,
I'm not,
I can't say that.
I mean I'm not in a position where
I could eat all my meat like that,
but I think that's the right way to do it.
I think if I didn't have this kind
of traveling standup comedy schedule,
if I was able to live in one
place for long periods of time,
I would do that.
That would get all my meat from game.
I think if you want to choose to eat meat,
that's the most honest way to do it.
Not saying there's anything
wrong with having a steak border.
Farmers come to like the big city.
I'd be like,
dude,
you can just find me at the
supermarket you don't like.
It's just so much better.
Why are we fooling ourselves?
Are you this and this?
It's the most honest way to get your meat.
I think there's something about farming,
much like something about
hunter hunter on it.
I think there's something primal about it.
I do like picking something off of a
tree or Bush and eating it right there.
You know what I like growing it,
growing things lately,
man,
there's something cool that,
you know we went to Underwood farms,
they have this like a big farm where
you can pick out your own food.
He'd go and pick out your
own pumpkin's for Halloween.
You could pick out like all kinds of
different things that they grow there and
then you bring it back and you pay for it.
And I,
I looked at him like how
difficult would this be to do?
Because it seems like a really smart
thing to do to have like a bunch of food
growing in our yard.
So I have a place like what if we had
like death squad farms where we all,
we all grew our,
our our food like hired
someone to run a farm,
buy a piece of land,
set up an irrigation system and that way
we know where all our Kale comes from.
Our strawberries come from.
That seems like that would be a toggle
rhubarb's obviously step one on the way
to the cult compound slash.
Farm.
But we start with a farm because
nobody can argue with the farm.
If you start with a cult then
all of a sudden they're like,
hey man,
you guys just can't,
can't go.
I'll call to on us.
But you know,
if you started off with a
farm and like listen man,
I'm just going to make it tomatoes.
How long and how many years
before somebody is like,
so take up arms pretty quickly.
I think right away.
As soon as you start killing deer,
then we need guns to kill deer.
You know,
that would be this shit.
If you could grow your own food and live
off of wild game and vegetables that
you grow in that as a very
close to nature way to live.
The argument against killing animals
obviously is they're beautiful and you
know,
why would you do that and this and that,
but the bottom line is you,
you need to maintain populations
because if humans don't maintain the
population,
then we have to give up our spot as the
number one Predator and bring somebody
else in to Duke decided we would rather
kill a deer than have to worry about
heading one with our cars and worry about
all the different predators that will
grow in size and number if you are not
killing those deals because then they
have more food.
So it goes on from there.
Yeah,
that's well look,
a lot of folks don't realize that wolves
were a real problem in this world at
one point in time.
It seems so strange to say,
but like big bad wolf and Little
Red Riding Hood and all that Shit,
what all those stories come from is
at one point time wolves keys to kill
people.
It was normal in France.
Yeah.
I gotta I gotta pull this up because I
saw this and I just want to make sure
that I quote this correctly
because it's curry easy.
What?
The Wolf Crop?
Barely pig.
Yeah.
Wolves killed like 40 people and
then in the 14 hundreds in France.
In Paris for 40 fucking people.
Yeah.
The wolves of Paris.
He's such a horrible way to die,
dude.
You can't wolf
the wolves of Paris like walking dead in
1450 the animals entered into the city
during the winter through
breaches in the walls.
They put walls up the
kitchen to kick him out.
Wait how,
what year a wolf nit 1450 a wolf name
core Todd or bobtail was the leader of the
pack and reports of the animal being
reddish in color may be indicative of a
Liberian wolf,
perhaps having migrated
from the Pi Rennie's.
Hmm.
Eventually the wolves were killed when
the precautions furious at the desk lured
core Todd and his pack into this heart
of the city and they had the prescience
stoned and speared to death the wolves
in front of the Notre Dame Cathedral.
Wow.
They speared them to death
in front of the cathedral,
like a cornered the wolves,
like people were literally
fighting for their lives against.
Why do you know how
horrifying that must've been?
You know,
that's where the w the Werewolf,
the,
the myth of werewolves come from real.
Wolf's comes from real world walls
and walls being smart as shit.
They're so smart.
They seem like they're people.
They hunt in packs.
They have the Alphas and the Betas.
If they have a system,
power holes when solar system,
what's that naming this
market below houses down.
Oh,
the old days.
The old days before they
started smoking and he's,
they got him to cool,
cool.
Menthols and they just fucking ruined
their huff and puff it on the old ladies
clothing too.
And Try to fool a little girls.
Yeah.
They can talk in English back in the day.
Um,
so,
so that's what always
scares me about camping.
It's like what if one of those
things comes up in my tent?
Well,
it's a problem when you're
not armed and it's a problem.
There's not that many of you,
you know,
when,
when we were with,
um,
the media to crew,
it was a one,
two,
three,
four,
five,
six,
seven.
It was like all together there was,
I believe there was nine of us,
so there was quite a few.
If Pete may have those big wolf
just in the middle of the night,
just start to be a problem.
Like how long until the first person
that wakes up gets his gun out?
Yeah.
Well that's the middle of the night.
Did you see the gray?
Yeah,
but that's my understanding
about the grade.
Why did they always kind of one by one?
It's like,
just kill everyone.
There's the wolves.
12 if you wolves,
you can't do shit.
That's probably the only
realistic thing about the movie.
The older one at a time.
Sneaky.
Yeah.
Wolves are smart,
man.
They take their time when they were all
walking towards the trees and the one,
the one guy fell back a little bit
and they went nuts on him was like,
Hey,
they just could have
turned on the rest of them.
Yeah.
But they might not of the mind that just
that will wolves are very clever man.
That might be a realistic part of the
movie that they saw the people running
back with guns that
they would run away to.
We heard those wolves killed
kill a skunk or on his campaign.
Yeah.
It's just the yell they let out.
It's just so amazing.
They all just start howling.
Like we've done it where I was,
he didn't have to worry
about wolves hear him.
But they do have an Idaho,
it's not that far away.
You know,
they reintroduced him to
the United States in Idaho.
Yeah.
Well because they're worried about the uh,
the ecosystem.
They wanted to bring it back.
They wanted to reintroduce the predators.
It's really interesting cause it's
having a devastating effect on the game,
but it's also to keep the door
of the game populations in order.
But now that they're forced,
now they're forced to have wolf hunts
cause the wolf's don't have any predators.
And the wolves used to have the
Predator and the Predator was us.
So now people are hunting walls and now
of course there's a lot of people that
are upset that people are hunting
wolves and I used to agree with that.
I used to say,
wow,
you know the community on that
you can't hunt fucking wolves.
That's fucked up because I think there's
something majestic about a wolf and
there's something where
you're not going to eat them.
And people were like,
why would you be able to hunt wolves?
But now it's you can eat them.
Yeah,
but now as I get older,
I understand like you have to hunt
them to keep the populations in control
because if you don't,
then they start going after livestock
and they will go after people.
A woman got killed by a
wolf this year in Alaska.
If there's more wolves,
so then that becomes less food
for all of them to go around.
As those wolves die out,
they get crazy at the end and
that's when it becomes a real look.
If you have an overpopulation problem
with wolves and they don't have enough
food,
that becomes a real fun problems
that to the population of girl,
that's all fine.
Yeah.
So when everyone's looking at these
wolves right now and saying like,
oh,
I think it sucks that the people
who are going to hunt wolves,
like they have to hunt them now,
if you don't hunt them down,
we're going to get to a situation where
it's going to be a problem and the last
problem you want is a
fucking wolf problem.
Imagine Wolf start just jacking people
again on a regular base and we'll think
of how fucking stupid we were to let
ourselves get to a situation when we built
the the murderer population
back then people murdered.
Magic was walking down the
street on Pasadena is a wolf.
I've don't,
don't,
don't go outside all night packs
of them snarling eating babies.
Bears here in Pasadena.
That bear that keeps on
coming down from the woods.
It was going people swimming pools.
Yeah.
Well it's babies.
It's come down with its babies.
Before they've even had an Alta Dena.
They had mountain lions like chilling.
This lady's driveway.
They had one in Santa Monica.
Yeah,
they had a shoot.
It had to kill it.
Yeah.
That was a big one too,
man.
Yeah.
Was a big ass fucking
200 pounds.
Hey,
we made an agreement.
You stay over there and we stay over here.
Dude.
You Matt.
How big?
I'm saying 200 pounds.
I think that's how big.
It was fun.
I remember good dog,
like 90 pounds with Johnny Johnny's
one 40 it says way bigger than that.
Yeah.
She says,
oh my God.
Is it true?
Is it really 200 pounds?
I know they get that bag.
Was there any moment of like right
before you pulled the trigger,
did you like,
will you just zoned in on you like nothing
to think about what I'm about to do,
right?
No,
no,
no.
I didn't think that.
I just wanted to make sure
that I got the right shot.
It's hard.
200 yards is a really
far distance to shoot.
You know?
That's why it didn't.
I tried to get it,
the bolt to go through his heart.
It didn't go through his heart landed
right above the heart and a couple inches
of the hardware.
The spine is,
that's where it hit him and dropped him.
Um,
why did they tell you
not to go with the head?
Cause it's harder to hit mountain lion
killed and Santa Monica is probably
seeking at home.
Oh,
poor baby.
You think.
Oh
yeah.
Um,
how big is it?
Come on your fucks
while you're waiting for Joe to look at
that information and go buy it for the
Holocaust and the city on,
in terms of Amazon and city.
Very,
very powerful.
That was really weird that you
called me hooky mine earlier.
And you had no idea
that Pokemon in my car,
Joe,
maybe I did know.
Maybe I knew you silly baby.
You know I never talked about it
and I'm tuned into the universe.
I'm a hunter now.
The spirit of the wild
brain scanning me man.
Yeah.
How did that,
it's really fucking weird though,
cause I haven't,
I don't think I've told you or dude,
I'm Bro,
I'm a fucking brain scanner.
We've never done it.
But we've never talked Pokemon ever.
I've never told talk,
poke me ever to,
but if any one of us would
have a Pokemon outfit,
you would be the winner of that.
Campbell I aside from God,
I put it in my car on the way here.
I just got it this morning.
Brian.
I don't know if you know this,
but I know that you're a silly bitch.
You're stalking me hunting here,
aren't you?
I have no,
you're hunting bear
Pokemon.
I understand silly bitches.
Oh,
it's Halloween is coming up.
Halloween.
I hate it so much word.
So much pressure.
I got a gorilla outfit,
but it's way too hot.
I don't see how anyone could wear it.
Why is it pressure?
Are you so at negative and angry?
I don't put something on
and it's like if you don't,
then it becomes like,
oh,
you didn't get one of these.
It's also,
you gotta explain it.
I just want to,
ah,
come on.
All right.
It's like,
this is like,
it feels just,
it's so soft.
You just put it on.
It just feels like
you're everywhere you go.
Just so people know what your real
personality is like and be like mini dean
everywhere.
I fuck around man.
Just wear that everywhere.
Cool.
If we never addressed it.
If you wore that every pod.
Yeah.
Why not man smell so it's cool.
I like it.
And it covers up your headphones.
Yeah.
Makes you look mysterious back there.
Um,
that DJ who dead mouse.
You're uh,
you're pokey miles.
Have you seen dead mouses?
Kat Von D's Twitter lately,
by the way?
No.
Every single tweet is I love you.
I know.
I love you.
I love going there and love.
It's just so silly.
He makes good music.
They live together now.
She's hot as fuck.
God.
It's the worst.
When people fall in love and they
feel like we got to make it public,
it's possible.
Someone's,
everybody does it.
It's like,
dude,
nobody cares.
It's worse than eating babies and
shitting in people's mouths when they're
sleeping.
It's the worst,
the worst rev,
worst,
the worst thing ever,
ever,
ever.
Just so annoying and just like,
we get it,
we're all bored with you now.
Look,
let them be in their global what for
like a month that they keep hearing about
it,
seeing a post about it.
Funny,
waiting on an airplane and they put their
seats back and you were sitting behind
him and there were tweeting and there
were tweeting picks it up that way.
The worst,
that's the worst because
he cost the worst.
I had to sit in front of no
liens or seat back all the way,
just saying,
oh,
I don't respect the person's boundaries
in any way behind me are their feelings
that I might be crushing their legs?
No,
they're saying I would like my seat
to go back and I don't care about what
anyone else is doing that doesn't
get your legs out of the way.
Has a little button.
That's what you're allowed to.
So then you were allowed to go back as
far as they let you and what if they go
should go a little further back.
Where'd you go?
A little further back,
like as long as that
was what was agreed to.
And what did they let you go?
All the way back to where
you're lying on somebody's lap.
Would you do that?
Oh,
where'd you use your own mind and say
just someone sitting back there or you
need some yoga and some Vicodin.
I would never do that.
That's not one.
I would never smashed
their fucking legs with my,
with my chair.
It's a violent,
it's violence.
Like someone taking what?
You don't feel like you
want to pick your seat back?
At what point?
Make sure I do uncomfortable,
especially as being a challenge,
but I don't put it back because
someone is sitting back there.
But that's designed for that.
So they put this,
how far the design?
It's annoying.
You can't fucking,
you can't type on your computer.
Somebody leads back.
You need to get rich enough
to get a private chat.
Unless you can't ever,
you can't ever look at your
laptop when someone's laying back.
Oh,
he's talking about coach.
I forgot.
It's no worry.
Just shows a lack of
caring about other humans.
Doesn't art shows you want to lean your
seat back and I know that's the design.
That's the reason you're doing it.
But everyone does.
It is not a reason to do anything.
It is because everyone does it.
It's an agreement.
Yours,
you're less comfortable when
somebody smashing into your legs.
It's for then do it to someone else.
It's a horrible act.
It's a horrible self shop.
Fell Fish Act.
No it's not.
Yes it is.
Knowing how bad it is,
you have to deal with your one year
old whose legs didn't go off the chair.
I could see it cause he wouldn't know
what it felt like to someone to go back on
him
at all.
You are very tall guy and
your legs get in the way.
When someone tries to lean their seat bag.
If you crossing your legs you can't fit.
However,
me and Brian are stubby
and we fit in fine.
Perfect.
So it's a completely different situation.
You also are like,
that's like a version of a being like
a big giant fat guy that doesn't fit in
the seat.
I actually of like it when
I'm laying back and the one,
the ones in front of me,
he's laying back.
It's like a little sky mall blanket.
Feel more protect like no,
it's gonna rack me in the balls.
Scam all blanket cause are selfish.
Selfish,
selfish.
That's interesting.
I don't see it that way.
Really causing some pain.
I choose not to think about it
is not the cell causing me pain,
man.
No it cognitive.
Somebody else pain's back.
Some of the front of me
sending coach this weekend.
Do you have it hates that.
It's a worse sending coaches.
If you have,
if you have your thing out
and you're on your computer,
you can't be on your computer anymore.
It's too far back.
Yeah,
you can't.
That's it.
So that's annoying.
But yeah,
you'll still inflict that on someone else
for the joy of leaning a little if you
want to,
you can do that.
Yeah,
you're allowed.
The law allows it.
You're not there to visit.
Why government doesn't work
cause everyone's corruptible.
Yeah.
Where's the Dolphin?
It looks there.
You're not going to do anything there
to sit in your seat and you're there to
get somewhere.
You can make it less
painful airline's fault.
Not
because humans can't be
trusted to think about others.
You're like,
they let me honestly,
if they let you go as far back
as you want it all the way back,
a bunch of you motherfuckers
would keep doing it.
They would.
There was like,
I don't know what goes there,
so I'm just going to do it and then get
head because girls just would not be
able to help themselves and be
dicks right next to their face.
It's an asshole.
We don't know what's happening.
I agree.
Oh,
are you really exaggerating here?
I'm not.
Wait,
what do you feel like it's selfish?
One knows what it does to people,
but you do it anyway.
It's just a small selfish act.
I don't think it's that selfish.
No,
you don't.
I think it's something people never
think they're doing anything wrong.
No,
it's just you're very tall guy,
man.
It's very different for you than it
is for me or Brian Guy Behind you.
Do you look and say,
oh,
he's a tall guy behind me.
I'm not going to do this
and person on that plane.
You need to understand that you're tall.
You need to spend the extra $40.
Did the business upgrade
class or whatever,
exit row.
And that's what you see
a short person behind me.
I still don't leave my chair back cause
it fucking disrupt all your sweetie.
I'm just so selfless.
That's you,
Ari.
I just liked the fact that when
somebody does lean back and stiff going,
ma'am,
I'm very tall,
but he just goes and starts kicking it,
like hitting him.
Whoa.
I think that was before he
did mushrooms this years ago.
No,
but he doesn't even
respond violently anymore.
You don't do that.
Sometimes I do this.
I say,
just so you know,
um,
you're going to make this
very uncomfortable for me
and I'm going to be paint.
I'm going to paint in my knee.
You said as you lean back,
but I know you're allowed,
but,
but just know that's what's
going to happen to me.
Why don't you just ask them,
would you please read your mind?
I had a knee operations and
I'm all fucked up and gangly.
Would you mind just that tall?
It's not crazy.
Five eight.
Yeah,
you are.
That's so Tom,
you're,
you're taller than average.
Most people are like me and Joe size,
but you know where that difference is?
You're just talking about knee to waste.
That's the only difference in terms
of where it affects your seat.
So those five inches,
seven inches.
I'm like,
how come I'm not going away?
It's going to be that much more.
He does
it.
Cap doesn't get crossed up.
You can do that weird thing where you
can actually fold one leg over the top.
My little troll legs don't work that way.
I can't fold my leg
over the top of my leg,
my legs.
I can only wear a certain types of pants.
Most pants I can't wear.
I can't like like Levi's five oh
one I can't even get those on.
If they were,
if they fit my waist,
they never fit my legs.
They get onto my legs and
they just lock up halfway.
Really?
Yeah.
Cause you have thick thighs.
Don't feel like a troll.
I'm five eight 190 pounds and most
of it's in my legs and my ass.
Five eight one nine.
You guys are both five eight
to 10 Jesus
men is so different than women.
If a girl ever did that to her friend,
what do you way to tent Jesus?
You'd be them to the
end of the friendship.
Isn't it funny?
Yeah.
Women are allowed to do that.
It's something they're allowed to do.
They'll do what allowed to keep that.
You know like you know half us to talk
about how much girl ways or you can't
like ask her and then like
get in her face like you fat.
Fuck.
You can't say that.
Putting it on the balance.
Yeah.
You can't say that you
were an asshole if you do,
but with guys like who you,
you fat,
fuck.
You know why?
First of all the time
have respect for women.
That's why we don't do it because
we're like they can't handle it.
Those little babies that we can't
fucking trust with real feelings.
Well we have testosterone.
Testosterone's was fucking speaker
zig for frothy loads by the way on and
is going to have a testosterone boosting
formula.
We found out there's a bunch of things
besides the zinc and magnesium does
something called tongue.
Got Ali and there's a bunch of different
herbs that have been shown in an actual
real clinical tests to up testosterone
when you take them for more than 10 or a
10 or 11 days.
Yeah.
Aubrey,
we were saying that he tried the
Zma Max or whatever that does.
Same thing was,
and it just made him
shit a lot like diarrhea.
Whoa.
And I didn't have,
no,
I never,
I've never had their probably he must
have got a bad batch or it was confusing
it cause he was also
doing Tequila and stuff.
The isolated,
I met a dude this weekend who uh,
had a stroke from meth.
Wow.
Yeah.
We uh,
we went to a bar and there's,
this guy came in with his friend,
his friend was 25 years old
and he had a stroke from,
from doing math at one 2123.
Yup.
That's crazy.
Yeah.
He's learning to like read,
reuse his body again.
Fucking crazy.
Math is a mother fucker.
Wow.
That's one thing that you have to
deal with in like places like Montana,
you know there's a lot of math problems.
So those places I make a joke swap pill
sometimes and I get away from La to New
York.
I think all you're not going to
get it cause you guys don't you.
And then it hit me like Indianapolis,
Kansas City.
I'm like,
Oh yeah,
this is where pills are.
This is where method.
Oh yeah.
Pills are everywhere,
man.
We live in a really strange world
because in the middle of this,
this whole debate on marijuana that
keeps going on in the public eye,
when you see it on CNN
and there's hills or yeah,
while this is happening,
well this marijuana distraction,
there are so many pill
junkies this country.
So Monster,
monster numbers and no
one's doing shit about it.
There's a lot of meth heads in
this country too in the weeds,
doing shit about it.
And then you see cops that just dressing
up like high school students and
pretended to be high school students
trying to get them to sell them weed and
I'm like,
really?
Why?
Why are you not busting the meth labs?
You fuck you.
No,
you're not done.
You're not.
You didn't do your work.
You're going to go after high school kids
high school or selling marijuana will.
It should be the last
thing you have to get.
Exactly.
It should be.
Even if it's a layered,
all the murderer we've cured,
you know we resolved like who
committed all the murders,
put everybody in jail.
We've cleaned up the streets.
We were down to zero crime.
Okay.
How about high school kids
are so we'd all right,
we'll go back to that
and all have drugs first.
Well,
Utopia,
Ari,
I look like I'm the guy in the front.
You're so uncomfortable putting up a
picture that's kind of drawn in the same
way as the instructions that are in
planes telling you where the exits are.
But it's a guy very uncomfortable
with the seat and getting seats.
His knees smashed.
You should just jerk
off into people's hair.
I put it in there a little bit.
That would be very,
very rude.
It would be a violation of
it is fucking rude though.
How they shoved so many
goddamn seats onto a point.
Oh it's like cattle now.
Yeah.
I mean it's so,
it's such not a seat
when it's really funny.
As they tempt you at the airport,
at the airport,
you get to sit in those seats waiting
to get on the plane and those are,
those aren't bad.
Yeah,
it's a great and you're like,
hey,
okay.
Obviously you know what
size seat should be.
Okay.
Cause you got them everywhere.
You're teasing.
You're aware.
It's not like I have no
idea of why the size.
Yeah.
I'm all over his fucking gate
everywhere and then I get all,
you're like,
oh we forgot.
We forgot.
We forgot what size it is.
We're gonna make them half that size.
Right.
That's okay.
No it's not.
Okay.
Asshole.
Kalin and I were sitting next to
each other and I'm not a big guy man,
but I'm touching the airplane on my left
side and touching him on my right side.
Can we do three rows of two
instead of two rows of three?
That's exactly what it should be.
Yeah.
Just make it tighter to get it around.
But it should be rows of two and it
should be more space in between the rows,
you know,
and it,
I mean,
I guess you have to pay a little bit
more for that and people don't want to do
that.
But man,
I just feel like the way
they're doing it now,
it's just,
it's so Cadillac sucky beds,
like bunk beds style.
It should be people on top of people.
So like you're kind of laying
down and like a bunch of shit.
I want to be old people couldn't
hold people down the bottle.
Some old people can barely stand up.
The old feel of the seats can't crawl
out and just have a bunch of beds in the
back.
Yeah.
Was don't fucking too,
that's another problem.
That's not a problem.
That's living your life
won't be allowed to Hug Scott.
You say that.
All right.
Because you're what's called a pervert.
Your al young delinquent running around
out there with no responsibilities
trying to fuck on airplanes.
Okay,
but that's not good for society.
Have you reflect on it?
I'm trying to have jerked off an airplane
on an airplane.
If you are,
how dare you have only been
more chances in your life.
Yeah,
I just think that uh,
you can't give people too
many opportunities to fuck.
They would just never get any work done.
We never have iPads.
Fuck whenever they want to fucking,
yeah,
it would suck,
man.
They talked really loud or quiet.
Oh yeah,
baby.
Put it in my shitter.
Like,
Hey,
I'm trying to read.
Yeah,
you really fucking whore iPad.
I'm getting you guys
going to make me jerk off.
Okay.
I'm going to jerk off module.
Businessmen poked their
heads will go off on me.
Bro.
Took and my loads.
Don't shoot that far.
I'm aiming towards you.
It won't reach you.
Trust me.
He imagined he just jerking
off at straight out the guy.
He's like three feet away.
Like don't worry dude,
I'll never hit.
And then just by some crazy streak of
red wine to hit the longest just shot
ever.
It's almost like,
you know like you manifested
it with the secret.
My friend Josh,
he laid on a table he could jerk off
and hit the ceiling lower ceiling.
This is like,
I'll bet you all right now.
And we're like,
literally none of us want to watch.
Wow.
That's a guy who's just hoping,
oh gosh,
this isn't going to work.
Come on,
suck my cock.
Who wants in that is it?
It just wanted a bunch of
guys who watch some jerk.
Ah,
it was high school.
Of course I got squares.
He would have just like come to it.
Just dripped out to cut to
that guy right now is there.
They're roasting him like a pig over-haul.
One guys kept wanting his ass.
One guy that's got one of his Dick and
they got him hogtied did just spinning.
I'm
spinning them button mouse.
It's better than high school.
Wouldn't even watch the shark.
That guy's gay as fuck.
Even thinking about it.
That's not a rotisserie right now.
Spinning around Cox.
Well,
people just on the
sides and glaze them up.
Imagine the scenarios that were gay
before you knew what gay was or were aware
that it was actually going to be around.
I was around,
I knew what gay was really young.
I moved to San Francisco,
a family did when I was seven,
my and our next door neighbors were gay
and my aunt used to go next door and
smoke weed with them
and get naked with them.
But yeah,
because they were gay,
they didn't,
they didn't want to have
nothing to do with her.
So she would take off,
they would all take off all their clothes,
they would get high together
and they would all play Bongo.
And I was like seven,
you know.
And I remember it like they
were like really friendly there.
They weren't creepy at all.
They were very nice.
They were very nice neighbors.
Yeah,
they were very nice people.
That's cool.
And so my earliest,
uh,
my earliest encounters with
gay people was very positive.
It was like our neighbors were gay.
Really Nice guys and the
whole neighborhood was,
nope,
nobody's a big deal.
Yeah.
San Francisco was really
fucking gays in the 70s.
It's interesting how there's like
places that I was Asian back then too.
There was always a lot of Asians was.
Um,
it's interesting how
places back then like,
like there's like places
that are just decidedly gay.
This is the gay or like Santa Monica.
Like here's the gay area.
This is Santa Monica Boulevard,
West Hollywood.
This is the gay area if I called it Mecca.
Yeah.
Oh yeah,
for sure.
For Gay dudes.
Mecca,
Hossam Gay dudes,
man.
I'm telling you,
besides the persecution and the fact that
people don't want him to get married,
they have the fucking life,
you know,
if they really enjoy being gang,
I'll take a walk with
you one day down near my,
no,
no you won't.
I'll be in my car.
Windows rolled up,
sunglasses on,
walked by these places.
No one recognized
they Daniel Boone hat on fake mustache.
They all sit there and they're like
get wings during the day and stuff.
And he drank and tall and they're
all just smiling and happy.
Great.
And it's like you're all just
around pussy all day long.
You're just in a good mood.
Yeah,
they have good jobs.
They don't wait.
I don't want pays their own way.
And women will look,
some women get just happy.
Someone would get turned on by guys
that are fucked up and perverted and
aggressive and they get turned on by,
you know,
by just,
just,
just be manly shit.
Like man,
leave violence sort of be heated.
But some women don't and they'll,
the blonde one thing is the women will
never totally understand it because
they're not a woman.
Just like a man's never going to
totally understand what it's like to be
pregnant.
Never be able to wrap your head around
wanting a baby to grow inside you or
wanting a dick in your
mouth or in your pussy.
There's,
you're,
you're not going to have to
wrap your head around that.
You're not a woman.
And I think the gay guys have going
for them is their fucking men.
They understand what it's,
what it's like to be a man.
There's no confusion there.
Turned on by men and they are men.
So it's like everybody
knows what the fuck is up.
Whereas it's not like this charade that
you have to play when you're trying to
get a girl to,
like you have to ask for like a Bj
or something and he looks at it.
If that was a man there,
he'd be like,
Oh,
you're drunk.
Let me blow.
Yeah,
I can get you to bed.
Yeah.
Well,
unless he was a greedy bitch
didn't want to blow you,
just wanted you to blow him all the time.
Apparently there's that,
that happens in a lot
of gay relationships.
This is weird.
Like master slave sort of thing.
Yeah.
Uh,
this was here too.
It's mostly not,
but fucking,
yeah.
That's why he's here.
Almost all oral on handjobs.
Handjobs how dare you,
how Horny Hornier you.
How dare they handjobs awesome.
Is inserting stuff into
her asshole as I fuck.
Oh,
well now you're talking
to a party that's like,
I should have mentioned it.
The freeze dried foods.
Once you had the hot water,
it all pops out.
Yeah.
Let the party,
the like the fucking uh,
Peter Pan.
What was every out of water through it.
What movie was that?
It was some fantastical movie.
It's,
it's interesting that people
have a problem with gay people.
It's interesting that people,
I think they worry about
gay people being pedophiles.
There's a big difference between being
a pedophile and being gay and there's a
lot of gay people that want them.
Nothing to do with the young guys.
In fact like I want to
Brian Collins friends,
it was a gay guy and he was attracted
to guys like John Mccain's age.
He's attracted like older business.
My friend Rachel send
to girls that are older.
She was like,
yeah,
I'm thinking this 52 year old.
And I was like,
Ooh,
Rachel.
But then I realized the 52 year
old just getting a younger chick,
maybe she likes it because she takes
care of her or something and shit.
She goes,
shut up.
And I'm like,
is it,
is wrinkly grey skin slops and on
her face like dead octopus swapped
over your lips to your ears all.
She doesn't stick her tongue out.
Unenthusiastic Lee and the big lesbian
just grinds are split on their tongue.
Just keep her,
keep her town.
That face hugger pussy just
rubs up and down every time.
She doesn't really lick the pussy as much.
Just sits there with their tongue
out and this look on her face.
He's like,
yeah,
that's a big fucking giant
floppy face hugger pussy.
Fucking right there.
I'm fucking right there.
You betcha.
I'll keep in touch with her tongue out.
I'm getting thirsty.
I'm almost done.
Matt.
Just someone's complaining
like you don't know.
When you complain about getting thirsty,
she starts from scratch.
You fucking selfish combat.
Keep your tongue out there
and shut the fuck up.
You want to do you want
to drive a range rover?
You do.
Okay,
well this woman's going
to get you a range rover,
but you've got to keep your tongue out.
Hung out.
Keep the oil price to pay for Range Rover.
It was off road range rover.
You fucking bitch are fucking range rover.
Restive female gay
people angry about gays.
What is that exact?
They're fools.
No,
no,
but where is it?
I don't think it's dad.
I think they're scared.
They're scared of that somehow
or another that the gay person,
some my is going to get ahold of them
and turn them into a gay person or some
tutors so scared of being gay that they
will not let a woman touch their asshole
or do anything with it because gay people
have used that and an act somewhere.
They will not allow a woman to make it.
They can't even appreciate
on body in any way.
Yeah.
To or were were suppressed.
We're all fucked up,
man.
I can't,
I can't fucking do that shit.
You can tilt down a you.
I'm like,
I know.
That's the way
sound like fun at all.
That does not sound like fun.
A girl putting on his trap on a fucking,
you know like who are you and what
are you trying to do because okay,
you don't even feel that strap on.
You create that.
Just not like it's a part
of your body receives it.
Like fucking hookers with Dildos,
pushing it into a really don't
get the same sort of thing.
Me Neither,
but everybody's got their own thing.
It's got their own thing.
Nothing wrong with it.
As long as you make an
agreement with a hooker,
you know,
you listen right before I come,
I got to stick.
Might need my finger right here.
Yeah.
You wrap it down.
Um,
it's uh,
you know,
sex is such a weird thing because it's
all just about what feels good to your
body.
That's what it's about.
It's about people doing things to each
other's body that makes them feel good,
but they're so negative connotations.
First of all,
the diseases,
that's a big one.
I read that like gonorrhea,
that there were something like 300,000
cases of gonorrhea in America in 2010 can
America?
Yes.
300.
I'll look it up right now because I think,
yeah,
300,000 cases of gonorrhea.
It's one out of like 1300 people.
Yes.
I know.
1300 people.
Oh,
of course.
I know some other kind of retail.
Yeah,
that seems about right.
I just got it.
Just got it.
I mean,
we're shocked with crabs.
Like I never was crabs anymore.
According August nine 2012
they approximately 340 case
of gonorrhea each year.
A hundred 300,003 in America.
In America.
I was right.
Wow.
That was gonna be one that comes back
and it gets cured or is that the one that
you can forever?
Yeah,
you cure it.
You get a little shot of penicillin.
That's the one he didn't border like
empire with the shoe thing up your dick
hole and pull up strain.
So let's stop and think about that.
There's probably a lot of
money and treating gonorrhea.
I think about the amount of money.
What if we found out like the medicine
responsible for treating gonorrhea was
also responsible for commercials.
It shows chicks acting like whores.
Like he thought they were selling Nike's,
but really they're selling pussy
because it's partially sponsored by the
gonorrhea medication that
is trying to get them going.
Yeah,
like gonorrhea mercenaries
and they'd go out there,
they give them gonorrhea and then
there's like the guys that are studs,
they just got to fuck a lot of bitches
and they create like a hole in festal
hold town with gonorrhea.
Just so they can sell or trying to sell
people to stop smoking so it can chew
gum.
And I found out he was from
the truly come factory.
Oh really?
Oh,
that's hilarious.
Yeah,
that'd be hilarious that they
were doing that to spread disease.
Yeah.
Bring down girls.
They make,
they may porn everywhere.
They tried to just make
it have more gonorrhea.
Well you know,
that's a weird thing about the strange
groups of like the like the branch off
groups of gay people that branched off,
you know,
those weird branches.
Those uh,
what,
what does,
what does the expression,
not branch off,
but uh,
whatever,
what I'm talking about is bug chasers.
Oh,
you're wanting to do,
to go out and try to get HIV positive.
They want guys to shoot loads in
their ass and make them HIV positive.
It's like what are so tied in with like,
this is a gay disease grids.
Yeah.
That is a crazy request though.
That's my thing.
Idea that you want to go and get aids.
Like you're,
you're trying to go out and get HIV.
Like what?
That's,
but that just goes to show you that
there's that many people that their people
are so fucking nuts.
There's a certain amount of people they
want to tattoo their face and stretch
out their lips and stretch out their ears.
You know,
there's a certain amount of people
that want to fucking you pierce.
Their dicks is a certain amount of
people that want aids aids through people
with those giant,
like this big round,
like half dollar full corn
dollar size earrings in.
Really pushed it out in a girl.
And the guy came up to me after Portland
and said hi and stuff and I was like,
oh,
are you guys together?
Both of you crazy ears.
Yes.
Restaurant that we were at in Montana.
I had to do too.
Is working there?
Has Ears like that?
It's like a two years going back.
No,
no.
You have to get them stitched up.
Ah,
yeah.
That's no joke.
That's pretty serious.
The,
I mean,
literally they have to go in and they
have to pull your fucking meet together
and stitch it up and they probably
have to cut some of it off.
Oh yeah.
He would have to cut some of that off.
You'd have to cut some of it off.
Yeah,
it's fucking Gross,
man.
It's a weird thing that people want to do.
Like I saw this pretty girl the other day.
She's really pretty.
She came to the show and afterwards
she had this giant ring in her nose,
like a bull ring and ask for it.
Yeah.
I was like,
Eh.
I mean the aesthetics,
I'm not into it or not into it,
so I can go chat to though.
Right?
Yeah.
I don't want any of that.
Like that.
That's hot.
Yeah.
Especially if they're good.
It's good work.
It's good clear.
And it's got red and black,
not just all black.
It's like,
Ooh.
Yeah.
And it also shows she's just dirty.
She's just getting drilled on.
She could take the pain.
That's a girl could
take us serious fucking,
you know,
girls who like complain a lot about stuff,
you know.
So we've got their phone on 20 folks.
That was one of the weirdest thing,
man,
is that this little thing called
vibrate and I forgot about it.
That's one of the weirdest things
about being there was no cell phone,
no email,
no,
no nothing for five days.
That must been cool.
It was strange.
You got a lot of energy,
a man wondering how much just from that,
not the being outside.
All of the above.
All the above.
I think it's walk around.
I left my phone at home last night for
four hours at this comedy store in your
hand,
but I did a lot of purpose.
I was like,
now let me leave it here to
charge low and it was like,
I'll be okay at fucking 11:00 PM at night.
Took to whenever you're talking about
like down the street from your house.
I was like,
nobody.
Yeah,
but you still got to concentrate on it.
Yeah.
We're eventually going to
become a symbiotic machine.
We're going to be part
machine thinks that this,
it's just the going that way.
It would have to be,
we're already connected to your phone
mean what difference does it make if you,
if they told you that we have a
new phone that's more effective.
If you don't carry it,
we inserted into your
thigh and they forgot away.
Oh,
by the way,
Brian,
we,
uh,
we're,
we're going to be able to upload all the
shows live on youtube as well now and
we'll be able to a stream them on youtube.
We've got a new thing going on.
We're going to be able
to live in u street.
No,
no,
no.
We're going to do at the same time.
Simultaneous,
simultaneous.
How about that?
That's possible,
right?
Yeah.
Uh,
two feeds to video feeds and
get some hardcore bandwidth.
Okay.
Uh,
we're going to
get the guests to computers or something.
I Dunno.
That's kind of tricky.
Let's see if we can try it because
otherwise we can at least upload them.
We can start uploading
them to use youtube.
Yeah,
I did prom might have with youtube is
that I've always tried to do the live
streaming thing or you know,
and it never,
it always never works.
Right.
Crashes or maybe we could try it.
We'll try it.
We'll see what's up.
I don't know what my Internet's
like at the new place.
Will suit,
won't see until they're putting
the bricks on the walls.
This week I'm making it fancy folks
making it like a Billy Joel's Italian
restaurant.
That's the thing.
Vytorin embattled white,
whatever kind of moon.
Uh,
yeah.
I just thought that they can get bricks.
Uh,
first of all,
the reason there's two reasons
for putting bricks in the wall.
The number one reason is to
Joey Diaz the room at the fuck.
I got a joy.
D has proved his cock sucker.
The uh,
the,
there's a business next door and I don't
want Joey screaming through the walls.
I don't think it would show up,
but,
so I'm,
I'm taking significant
steps to what deaden the,
some of the sound in the room.
And one of them is to put up a brick wall.
Yeah.
I mean super.
It's just get a big bubble when the
bubble boy bubbles for Joey Diaz and just
have him walk around
like a hamster anyway.
Plastic and just going for it.
Yeah.
I'm a,
they take bricks that they like wreck a
building and they take bricks and they
sliced the veneer off the brick and then
they could put that on a regular wall
so it adds like another wall layer,
you know.
So I figured that would be a
pretty good to prevent some sound.
And then I'm also got these curtains
that are going up that have like a sound
deadening backing to them
putting those up as well.
Yeah.
And a I just taken,
it's taken some time folks,
but it's because I'm doing it while
I'm doing all these other things.
At the same time,
if you're,
the customer over under this week is
going to be the bricks that we'd done.
The desk is done.
So I have all the equipment in.
So not,
not that bad.
Once the uh,
once the bricks are up on the wall and uh,
I got the wall painted.
Yeah,
I think so.
I think in December,
I think my goal is before we do the
end of the world show with honey,
honey and Diaz and Stan hope that we
do a podcast like the night before that
would be my goal is to open up the studio
that week and do a do a podcast there
the night before.
But once we have it,
once we have an up and running,
it's going to be,
uh,
just,
I just want to get a place that's
going to be a place that we can kind of
completely control the environment and
make it like as cool inside as I can,
you know,
set it up as technologically perfect,
technically perfect,
really nice big desk and,
and have it a fairly close to,
uh,
this place has really
become fucking high tech.
Well,
not the core.
I mean it's really,
it's like this is inside Brian's brain.
If you could open up his brain with a
can opener that Hitler Zombie would pop
right out.
I had a crazy ass dream the other night,
man.
Weird Alpha brain did.
I was on a,
what do you got?
Their fellow Koser.
Yeah,
you tail.
Okay.
This man's almost 40
clutching a coke zero like he's in prison.
Are you going trick or
treating and with the fam?
Oh yeah,
Bro.
That's a cool part of
Halloween that I would do.
We did it.
Um,
we went trick or treating in Disneyland.
Oh Wow.
People can figure neighborhood did it?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
We're going to go.
Um,
we're going to go walk the neighborhood
to the community that I live in has like
a little friends that they
have like a little party.
They have like a live DJ and stuff.
It's kind of fun.
When did Wednesday,
Wednesday is the day that I have to
turn off all my lights and not answer my
door.
Why?
Why is that?
Because it's annoying
and be like,
no,
that is mine.
I like to hide.
Ding Dong.
Yeah.
I'm flying to Calgary
this year on Halloween.
I got out of it before it was Halloween.
I was like,
Oh fuck yeah,
let's do that.
Yeah,
you're working.
Where was the club in Calgary.
Okay.
Oh,
powerful Yuk Yuk.
Ladies and gentlemen.
Head on out to see how re
motherfucking shoe here.
You were with me in
Calgary right this year.
Yeah.
Get a lot of people come from that show.
That was an man.
Yeah.
And I bet you have a
lot of new shit anyway.
You've been working on a lot of Shit,
right?
I'm starting to do this one.
One of the cool things about everybody
doing all these shows and putting out cds
like yours and Joey's is a,
you know,
we're,
we're constantly putting a new material.
Yeah.
It's fun.
So I can feel very reasoned to.
Yeah.
I feel very challenged,
you know?
Yeah.
It feels fun.
I haven't really felt like
this since open mikes.
Yeah.
I don't know how it was in Boston,
but in la it was the same
people seeing you all the time.
So really every week I did have
something new or you're an asshole.
You know,
we're getting a lot of these
people that are just like,
you know,
that come into a lot of this year.
So at least every year it's a crazy
little grateful dead thing going on.
We're fine.
Fit for me.
And Juliet in Chicago
November 8th by the way,
that has the blues people are flying
in people I'm making like meetups and
stuff.
Of course here I can.
I love that shit.
Yeah,
we're going to have to figure out our
own gathering of the Juggalos types.
Yeah,
no that's,
Duncan wants to do it in the desert,
man.
I want to go out with Manson.
I'm telling you the palm springs area.
We'll get it handled.
So many mushrooms.
Yeah.
Would
you ever do this?
Uh,
this the guy who hosts the pock,
I've talked about him before.
He's like almost apocalyptic.
Yeah.
Post apoc.com guy.
Oh he,
he's the one that sent me that package
once where I thought it was a bomb or
something and it just ended up being
a really cool pipe that he made.
He's always sending me like cool things.
Anyways,
he goes to thrift stores and
buys old bottles of sodas here.
I get to the point he drinks them.
So this is like an eight,
like a 70 year old bottle of grape soda.
Dude.
I did.
I trusted her coke original.
He's wanting to break
that rest flattish shit.
Right?
Well it's,
you're not,
it's acidy and shit like that.
Is that as our work
in the background?
Yeah,
I think so.
That is a bad ass picture of
the dude with the gas mask.
His website's really bad by the way.
The new hire primate gas mask monkey sure
is available and plus pictures of a 40
go to higher-primate.com but he drinks it.
I made sure that it tastes like shit.
It's like,
you know,
copper almost and that,
okay,
well let's let him talk.
Okay.
Instead of a rubber gasket,
it's real cork.
Cork,
real cork would disk
inside the bottle cap.
I thought that was botulism or fungus
of some kind when I first opened it that
we're going to have to
end this video early.
Um,
we help us up the light.
We saw no floaties.
Who was he talking about?
No monsters are little squids or anything.
It's talking about himself.
Emily's personnel.
Your name or guy.
He's like Roy Jones Jr
strongly like grape Dimetapp.
I mean,
super strong,
great flavor.
This can be fermented to all hell
and extra for this down my throat.
And you'll see it just
burn right through my desk.
Squad shirt right here.
I really are.
We watching a guy just drinking soda?
Yeah,
but it's like from the 19,
1947.
All right.
Your tastes like grape flavor,
like nasty pond water.
It's a,
okay.
That really wasn't that interesting.
Just thought it was weird.
I mean,
what would you do that I just,
I drank a bottle of
coke zero coke original.
How these three of them save from uh,
when I was little,
little really real.
What it tastes like.
Super flat coke,
super flat coke.
Pretty much coke.
He ends up puking and slightly off,
but not much muck cars.
Does he really?
Yeah,
he sends up because of it.
It's just silly bitch.
And that's why you drink that?
Well,
I don't understand what people would
like think that it's interesting to drink
something gross that's been
around for a little bit.
Probably.
If you look at last that long,
like a wine then sure,
whatever.
But if it can't last that
long and what are you doing?
It's gone.
It's gone rotten.
That's a weird thing
that people do with ones,
you know,
keep wines around for hundreds of
years and drink them or scotch.
I love it.
That sounds like hoarding behavior.
That's like there's only a few left.
Just don't gotta wait.
Yeah.
That's what I do with weeds now.
I'll have like a few different strains
of weed and if it would be good,
I've got through half of it
right away and they'll be like,
oh,
we only have like half of it left.
It's when it gets like slower,
but I use it and then I only go
back to it every couple of months.
You hoard it like the last of the Maui
Wowie let's just slow it down a little.
What would you do that
we need to just get more.
I,
I always sort of forget.
I can go get more.
I don't want it to be gone.
That's a problem with living
in parts of the country.
That's not like California.
The world really would change if the
rest of the country was like Colorado and
California.
Those are the two places where
you can get weed anywhere.
Did they not shut down
dispensaries in Colorado?
No.
Only only here.
Yeah,
they shut them down a lot more here.
I'm sure they have shut down
some of them in Colorado,
we're a lot more of
like on the radar there.
Atlanta,
they're on the radar and Colorado man,
there's a lot of people
focal point to us here.
But the accepted,
and
I think it's more accepted by the people
in Colorado than it is the people of
La,
the people of La,
this little bit of a battle in Portland.
It was just everywhere.
Oh yeah.
Cause they're all fucking nature boys too.
So they'll grow shit.
It's part of the garden we plant too.
There's some likes their own weed.
It's smart,
smart places and smart places.
Like I'm not pro,
I'm not pro drugs period because
some drugs are fucking terrible.
I'm not pro pills.
I'm not pro math.
I'm not pro that.
But if you're not pro,
we'd even have to be a
fucking idiot if you,
if you really think that there's
something wrong with it and it's bad for
society,
you got to be an idiot or you're ignorant.
You don't understand what's really
going on with it because it was really,
what's really going on is not a bad thing.
It's a,
it's a humbling thing
that everybody could use.
A little bit of humbling.
Sure.
There's going to be some people that
just sit around and smoke pot all day and
don't get anything done,
but that's a psychological problem that
they have issues that that issue could
manifest itself that way or it could
manifest itself by them being perpetually
late or it can manifest.
They could fucking sabotage themselves.
People have weird issues so they could
sabotage themselves with weed or with
anything else they choose to do it with.
That doesn't mean that it
can't be used the right way.
Do you think people are burnouts because
of weed or they're just burnout and
then they would lose?
I think they are burnouts for weed.
Weed helps it along too.
Well.
Anything can help you along
if you don't have any resolve,
if you don't have any fucking disaster,
shit,
weed.
It's a little bit of that.
Yeah.
You smoked that thought of it.
Yes.
Come on Dad.
Chronic dog.
Some people that just hasn't
been had some weight loss,
so that's true too.
Yeah.
There's some people where every look,
people get fucking sick
if you get the nuts,
could not get high.
Yeah,
and then I go,
oh,
I told you about it.
Yeah.
Amazing.
Yeah,
I heard that works with Dmt to the
certain people that just can't,
DMT just doesn't work on them.
Small percentage of people,
but every now and then I heard somebody
went to float lab and she was just like,
no,
that wasn't really hallucinating.
It was just like,
yeah,
float lab,
that's tank or whatever.
That takes some time.
The float tank is not a,
it's not like instant hallucinations.
You got to really get comfortable with
letting go and I'm like you finding like
the center of your thoughts.
That's not an easy,
it's easy to distract yourself.
I said,
what's your,
what would you try to do?
You got to get strong mentally,
you have to learn how to meditate.
When you get into a float tank,
it's not as simple as you get in there
and you start tripping because you get in
there,
you're still thinking,
I'm like,
God,
I'm floating.
I'm like,
God,
this feels weird.
Where's the side?
It's right here on my balls.
Itch.
You start thinking a
bunch of different things.
You have to have control of your mind.
It's not as simple as you
get in the float tank,
boom.
You have hallucinations.
You have to get in the full tank and
you've got to start that process on your
own.
You have to center yourself.
You have to concentrate
only on your breath,
drop everything slowly but surely.
Remove all the layers of consciousness,
all the layers of letting go until you
get to the center and that's when you
start having these crazy
visionary experiences.
That's kind of like a same thing.
I'm sure mushrooms,
it's like when you were talking to
your friends and laughing and stuff.
It's fun.
You know?
Listen,
I could,
and then you just stop and
like look up at the and just
don't talk or listen to anyone.
That's when he started seeing shit.
Yeah.
It's guy just was telling me the other
day about the same thing that he went and
he was more of just like,
all right,
I'm just bored and you know,
I'm just laying here.
This is really stupid.
Oh really?
Yes.
Well if he,
if you don't know how to use it.
Yeah.
Anything else?
You know,
you have to learn how to relax.
I don't run your thoughts of all of them.
You for the idea behind the sensory
deprivation tank is that there's no input
coming in and when there's no input
coming in and you could just sit there and
go,
oh,
socks on board.
Or You could just slowly let go of all
your consciousness to the point where
you,
you are just your mind.
Untethered from culture,
from any interactive
experience with nature,
with,
with gravity,
with seeing things or hearing
things or touching things.
You removed from all sensory input.
And when you do that,
you can have very clear
and intense thoughts.
And you can also have some pretty powerful
hallucinations if you allow yourself
to manifest those ideas.
But you have to learn
how to let go to do that.
You can't just get in there.
It doesn't just happen right away.
You know,
you start thinking about your life,
you start thinking about
things that you can't avoid.
You start thinking about things
that had been bothering you,
like about yourself.
Oh,
you know,
well,
no,
not necessarily.
I mean,
it depends on what's
going on in your head,
but for the most part we just sort of
accentuates experience on a small version
of this plans.
Recently I've just taken some
pock cookie or something.
It's going gonna be a long
flight and just so you know,
I'm not getting anything done here,
but it's not,
but I'm not tired when I've slept and
it's like I like 2:00 PM flight or
something that I just look out the
window and I just stare out the window.
I'm just let my mind
just go the entire time.
Yeah.
The only way I get a really get blasted
these days is on planes because when I
interviewed enough from
the outside can help you,
like just start like a synapse
going a little bit sure out.
Also it's like the only time I
don't have any responsibilities,
I don't have to take care of my kids.
I don't have to be,
you know,
sober.
There's no Wifi in the,
it's even better.
It's like I can't do anything.
It's a great way to write to
10 minutes about the per trip.
Well I'll leave it,
I'll leave it on my lap and just like
if I get a thought that I'm like,
oh gosh that could work.
As I quickly write it down,
I type so much better than I write.
I'm really,
I've hardly write anything anymore
and I can type pretty quick.
I type really quick now so I have to type.
But I like it.
Man.
I really love writing on playing.
It's one of my favorite things.
I write some of my best shit ever.
I'm plans high as fuck.
I've really started flying
later that now so I can do that.
Yeah.
Cause it is a good place to just get
away from everything and like get things
done.
Yeah.
When you're sitting in that seat you
got nowhere to go and you've got that
laptop open,
you can get slips or noon.
I'm not,
you know,
and then it's just like now it's,
yeah.
Don't you,
do you feel now that you're,
you're having all this success
and things are going well,
you feel like even more motivated.
Like you're like fucking really hustling
now and really putting in the work to
add more stuff or more,
isn't it fun?
My next thing I like how like like motion
begets more most yet people or force
of habit.
Yeah.
I think that's what it is and where
be able to work out all the time.
It's just like that,
that's your habit and when
you do the Joe all the time,
then that's your habit.
Yeah.
And that's one thing that people have
kept telling me over and over again from
this podcast.
One of the things that they pull from it
is that it's changed the way they sort
of address and approach things.
And people,
you know,
sometimes people just need to hear
something and it's like one things,
reasons why I love that book.
The war of art.
I probably understand and I've thought
most of the things in that book on my own
independently.
I think a lot of creative people,
it's not that you can't piece it together.
Sometimes you need to read it again.
You need to see it again.
You need to be reminded again.
You need to clear when it's written out
or when you can actually see it or when
it's spelled out.
When someone say's says it in a way that
resonates with you know how you feel
about the world.
And I think that's one way that we can
all help each other in a way that no one
of past generations was able to do.
One of the different things
about this sort of a medium,
like a podcast,
medium contact with everyone in the world,
quick contact with everyone in the world
and you can express things in a way
that you really couldn't do if you were
sponsored by Palmolive or fucking the
trucks.
You know,
it's like you would have
never gotten all these,
this information out as clearly
as we're doing it right now.
Yeah.
Just saying,
yeah.
Strange Times our issue.
Fear,
powerful,
Arusha,
fear of the skeptic tank on iTunes.
You dirty,
dirty bitches.
Checkout Ari's podcasts and buy his own.
Oh hell.
What happened?
He just talks about how he's able to
fucking well to fuck so much how he's
given,
how he's always had that power.
Well,
he's a smooth talker duties.
Amazing.
Smooth up.
Poveda do the can you do to out?
Yeah.
Check out my website already.
The great.com please,
please check out [inaudible] website.
I'll be in Chicago.
I know your back.
I love me and I'll love you back.
Number 10.
Um,
and uh,
you just got done doing a fucking return
homecoming gig and the place where you
started and you can't see conquering hero.
I felt good there,
if any.
Did you know how it's like at any level,
no matter where you are,
there's certain shows that
are just important to you
and it might not because of
money or anything you wanted
to let everybody know.
That's where he started out.
I had a bunch of friends
from high school came out.
It was kind of cool.
My aunt came.
That's how awesome.
It was just like,
and people are like,
oh,
it's like way different than last time.
I was a fucking wrote into
our fucking professional now.
Yeah,
it felt real professional.
You're legit.
Too legit to quit.
Hey.
Okay.
This weekend you fucking freaks San
Francisco at the Nob Hill Masonic Center.
That is November the second on Friday
and then Saturday night the Moore Theater
in Seattle and that shit is sold out.
Both nights will be Brian Red Ban and
Greg motherfucking Fitzsimmons with me.
So we're going to have some
fun San Francisco and Seattle.
You dirty bitches tomorrow.
The Great Duncan Trussell
would join us on the podcast.
Boom.
Halacha boy.
And we will also have
a podcast on Wednesday.
I'm not sure it was going to be,
we're working on a couple
of different guests.
Um,
what if you go to my website,
if you're poor,
I'm giving away for free tracks at my Ct.
Ooh,
look at that greats from Ari.
Of course it is.
That was why I was number one on iTunes.
Thank you.
Validation.
Thank you all very much.
Again.
Let's see if we can bring that
shit back to number one again.
I think the number one I'm,
but I'm going to go buy one as
soon as I get off the phone.
I'm not on the phone.
Am I talking about,
this podcast is brought to
you by [inaudible] dot com
Goto rogan.ting.com and
you will see $50 off of any android device
that they have and they have regular
cell phones too.
If you're one of those fucking Weirdos,
just once a day,
not be able to get on the
Internet on your phone.
Moved School,
fuck head.
Um,
checkout ting,
a very reasonable and
excellent cell phone provider.
They don't,
they don't cause con cause contracts.
They don't require contracts
and it's all spelled out.
I didn't make the Dang you son of a bitch.
I swear to God I did not do that.
Let's the FBI telling us our time is up.
Maybe it's you stream.
It was attending.
That's the thing.
What the fuck?
No,
we're still online.
Oh,
that's you.
You sign up for a while trying
to pull out of the water here,
but I'm like that easy.
We've got a joke.
I'd go to [inaudible] Dot Com o.
N n.
I.
T use the code name,
Rogan and save yourself
10% off any supplements.
That includes hemp force,
the delicious hemp protein
powder with Makkah and raw cocoa.
It's fucking delicious with Stevie.
Only one gram of sugar per serving.
It's not.
We don't even add that.
That's just what's in the hemp and all
the juicy good shit that we put in it.
All right.
That's the end of the podcast.
Thank you very much for tuning in and
thanks for all the positive tweets.
Thanks for all the love.
Thank you.
Anybody who comes to all of our shows,
we appreciate the fuck Adi guys squat.
Ohio death squad rolls on bitches.
Oh,
Death Squad Ohio is
November 11th it's sold out,
right?
Uh,
no,
it's eighth ninth and 10th and one only
this eight o'clock she Columbia shows
sold out.
Okay,
so which one would they just sold out?
A Columbus for show,
I believe is the one.
And what date is that though?
I said that night.
The 10th.
Okay.
So the folks say eighth and ninth it and
go to death squad.tv and you can also
pick up some super sexy
kitty cat t shirts.
It's cut to Columbus shows one Dayton,
one in Cincinnati.
And by the way,
Tom Segura is going and
if you haven't seen Tom,
he is fucking on fire right now too.
He's one of the best in the country.
He really is.
He's awesome.
Um,
and uh,
Tony Hinchcliffe as well.
Tony Hinchcliffe,
I couldn't be on a couple
and so it's Doug Benson.
Excellent show ladies and gentlemen,
an excellent show.
And also if you go to desk a lot.
Dot TV,
you can pick up some of Brian's
Funky psychedelic kitty cats and no,
that's not a Wendy's sign.
The fuck are you talking about?
And even though he's good,
they better dirty bitches.
Step powerful white castles
in the house as well.
Shout out,
shout out the
way out to white castle.
I'll give it up for
black people in general.
I have given up on the olive garden.
They do not want me to support them,
but white castle has been supporting
me by giving me a tee shirts,
I think.
I think that,
believe it or not,
the olive garden is too
white for Brian Redman.
Yeah,
they're too wide and Cassie's cooler.
We'll be back tomorrow family,
but it's over with the olive garden.
We love the fucking
shit out of you people,
and we'll see you soon.
We're not going anywhere.
We're gonna.
We're gonna roll on.
We're taking it to the next level.
I don't even know,
like nothing I've ever,
I fucking love you bitches,
Huh?
Okay.
Right.